[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat pour suivre au
plus près l'examen de la réforme des
retraites jusqu'au 12 mars minuit ici à
la Chambre haute du parlement public
snack qui bouleverse sa programmation
pour vous faire vivre ses débats
également sur son site web n'hésitez pas
à lire les articles de notre réaction
c'est sur public sénat.fr ou en
sommes-nous en ce 5e jour de l'examen de
la réforme et on cet après-midi qui
démarre et bien il reste un tout petit
peu moins de 3000 amendements au moment
où je vous parle très précisément 2988
amendement examiné d'ici dimanche et ce
matin le Sénat a adopté une des
principales propositions de la droite et
du centre la création d'un CDI senior
spécifiquement pour les salariés de plus
de 60 ans et sans cotisation familiale
pour l'employeur pour en parler on va
rejoindre Alexandre Poussard en tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle bonjour
Alexandre nous avons échangé nos places
par rapport à ce matin et donc ces
charges vous de nous raconter ce qui
s'est joué ce matin effectivement
Quentin il y a eu une vraie modification
apportée à cette réforme de retraite ce
matin avec ce CDI senior alors en quoi
ça consiste c'est un contrat de travail
pour inciter les entreprises à embaucher
des salariés de plus de 60 ans dans son
dans ce contrat il n'y aura pas de
cotisation familiale payée par
l'employeur et l'employeur pourra mettre
fin à ce contrat au moment où le salarié
aura le droit à sa retraite à taux plein
alors les sénateurs de droite et du
centre ont défendu une mesure en faveur
de l'emploi alors que le chômage des
seniors coûte très cher à notre
assurance chômage de virgules 4
milliards d'euros pour les demandeurs
d'emploi de plus de 60 ans Alors en face
la gauche de l'hémicycle du Sénat était
défavorable à cette proposition de CDI
seniors qu'elle a rebaptisé contrat de
dernier embauche en référence au contrat
de premier embauche qui avait valu de
nombreuses manifestations en 2006 et les
sénateurs de gauche ont dénoncé aussi
une proposition faite par le patronat
écoutez cet échange entre le socialisme
chanterelle et l'auteur de notamment
René Paul Savary qui est rapporté à la
République de cette réforme de retraite
sur le rapporteur Sabari vous aurez dû
renommer votre amendement l'amendement
Medef parce que c'est c'est une commande
directe du Medef cette mesure va dans le
bon sens à déclarer Eric chevet le
vice-président de la CPME on n'est pas
étonné de sa réaction parce que avec ce
CDI senior vous allez permettre au
patron d'être exonéré des cotisations
familles non je ne suis pas asservi au
MEDEF à tel point que j'accepte bien
volontiers l'indicateur je crois pas que
ce soit le Medef qui réclame
l'indicateur mais permettez-moi de vous
dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
voilà pour ce CDI senior qui a été
adopté par la majorité de droités du
centre du Sénat un CDI senior auquel le
Gouvernement est défavorable car il le
juge trop coûteux pour la sécurité
sociale voilà Quentin on va maintenant
passer au débat de cet après-midi merci
Alex effectivement prochaine étape dans
ce débat cet après-midi on va écouter la
gauche sénatoriale qui va proposer des
sources de financement alternatifs pour
notre système de retraite alors je vous
parle c'est la présidente Elian assassin
qui fait un rappel au règlement en
l'écoute c'est vous qui pénalisez la
population en leur imposant de la
souffrance au travail deux années
supplémentaires et en leur volant deux
années de retraite en bonne santé donc
n'ayez aucune hésitation
messieurs les ministres mais vous êtes
seul là pour l'instant monsieur Attal si
vous voulez apaiser vous consacrez aux
urgences sociales climatiques je vous
dis sincèrement retirer ce projet
retirer le de la séance dès maintenant
merci merci madame la Présidente acte
est donnée de votre rappel au règlement
monsieur le ministre
non très rapidement monsieur le
Président pour répondre à la présidente
assassy aussi rapidement oui j'ai
dénoncé ce week-end au moment du Salon
de l'Agriculture j'étais interrogé sur
le sujet un certain nombre de
déclarations et certaines déclarations
de responsable politique qui ont appelé
je cite à mettre l'économie française à
genoux et ce que j'ai répondu et je
l'assume
à genoux c'est le terme qui a été
employé si si et ce que je dis c'est que
quand on dit qu'on va mettre l'économie
française à genoux ce sont des usines ce
sont des travailleurs ce sont des
Français qui travaillent ce que j'ai dit
ensuite c'est que quand il y a des
blocages la réalité c'est que ce sont
souvent les plus modestes et les plus
fragiles qui sont les premiers impactés
par les blocages
et que comme je l'ai dit l'école blanc
comme on dit les cols blancs en général
ils peuvent télétravailler ils peuvent
aller travailler à vélo parce qu'ils
habitent à côté de leur travail par les
travailleurs les plus modestes et les
plus fragiles qui doivent se lever
prendre le métro prendre leur voiture
pour aller travailler c'est le premier
point deuxième point madame assassy je
vous ai entendu utiliser les sondages
comme argument c'est un beau débat de
savoir si les sondages doivent être la
boussole dans les votes et les décisions
que nous prenons moi je considère que ça
n'est pas le cas mais si vous considérez
que les sondages sont à ce point une
boussole pourquoi vous êtes-vous opposé
à la suppression des régimes spéciaux à
laquelle 80% des Français sont
favorables dans les mêmes sondages
par cohérence vous auriez dû voter en
faveur de la suppression des régimes
spéciaux c'est donc bien que les
sondages ne sont pas la seule et unique
boussole qu'il faut suivre au moment des
votes sinon vous auriez voté
différemment
bien nous allons donc reprendre la
discussion
c'était juste un rappel aux règlements
avec une réaction du ministre il n'y a
pas de débat sur ce rappel au règlement
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi mais nous allons pouvoir
continuer à débattre je pense toute
l'après-midi nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi de
conférences pour quelques minutes le
temps d'interroger avec Guillaume
Gontard bonjour vous êtes président du
groupe écologiste et ici à la Chambre
haute un mot sur cet échange qu'on vient
de voir à l'instant avec le ministre
Attal qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé vous
de ces propos du week-end
je dis tout simplement que c'est c'est
scandaleux de la part d'un ministre et
de la part de la période où on est du
moment où on est oui une mobilisation
une mobilisation forte sociale
d'entendre les syndicats d'entendre les
gens qui manifestent dans la rue et en
plus qui manifeste pacifiquement c'est
un droit j'irai même c'est un devoir
dans une situation dans lequel dans
lequel on est et donc je pense qu'il
faut que chacun reste à sa place avant
d'aller sur le CDI senior qui est
vraiment ce qui a été voté ce matin l'un
des l'un des articles forts qui a été
voté ce matin un mois aussi sur la
mobilisation de demain puisque on le
voit la France à l'arrêt c'est le
souhaite c'est le souhait de l'Inter
syndical qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir
comme répercussion sur le débat
parlementaire qui va se jouer demain
ouais c'est ce que je disais c'est un
moment important et je pense que ça peut
avoir les bailleurs immobilisations qui
va être très forte et derrière cette
mobilisation cette journée de demain
derrière on va attaquer on va parler de
l'article 7 du fameux reportage jusqu'à
64 ans et forcément il va falloir que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités et par
rapport à justement ces manifestations
cette unité syndicale ben que encore une
fois que le gouvernement appuyé par les
républicains refusent d'entendre le pays
souhaite gouverner contre le peuple je
pense que c'est un véritable problème
donc oui ça sera un moment un moment
fort vous le dites sur un thème de
Public Sénat il y aura bien un débat sur
l'article 7 demain dans la foulée des
manifestations a priori
la date et l'heure moi j'en sais rien on
a des amendements et on va avancer donc
on verra on verra sur l'avancement mais
je sais très bien qu'il y aura un débat
sur la terre que 7 et que ce débat aura
lieu après la mobilisation et les
manifestations de toute façon quand on
voit le dérouler des débats donc ça ça
ne fait aucun doute et c'est une bonne
chose on voit que la droite et notamment
le président Larcher souhaite avoir ce
débat à partir de 14h30 demain vous quel
est votre option dans ce débat bah moi
je mets quand même en garde sur une
chose c'est que c'est un débat important
qui sera regardé qui est attendu il faut
que chacun puisse s'exprimer on a
beaucoup d'amendements sur ce 1300
amendements je dis qu'il faudrait pas
non plus que le vote notamment de cet
article 7 arrive pendant la nuit donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on fasse
attention à ça je mets en garde aussi le
président du Sénat et je pense que si
voilà ce ce vote global sur l'article 7
arrive plutôt mercredi moi ça me
paraîtrait beaucoup mieux en tout cas
sur un ça de très près sur antenne de
Public Sénat nous serons en direct sur
cet article et peu importe l'heure de la
nuit à laquelle il est examiné un mot
sur la création de ce CDI senior par la
droite et le centre spécifiquement pour
les salariés de plus de 60 ans sans
cotisation familiale Pôle Emploi vous
avez voté contre pourquoi pour deux
raisons déjà en écoutant les débats et
j'écoutais Bruno Retailleau qui nous a
expliqué que le reportage à 64 ans
permettrait justement mécaniquement à
cet essai mot que le taux d'emploi des
seniors et puis maintenant on nous dit
ah bah non en fait ça fonctionne pas ça
ne marche pas donc il faut un CDI qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas un CDI puisque
c'est un CDI de deux ans en tout cas qui
est illimité dans le temps qui est
plutôt une une voix de garage donc il y
a déjà cette cette incohérence donc je
pense qu'encore une fois c'est
incohérence après incohérence mensonge
tromperie sur ce sur cette réforme donc
un moment donné il va falloir que ça
sèche je pense que ça commence à
réellement se voir mais on le voit à ce
chiffre 56% des 55 64 ans qui sont en
emploi en 2021 l'un des plus mauvais
taux d'emploi de seniors en Europe
comment est-ce qu'on peut améliorer le
prix sur ce CDI ce qui est quand même
une autre index
qui est aussi une autre incohérence
c'est qu'on va exonérer de charge
complète c'est-à-dire de participation
justement à nos retraites sur l'ensemble
de ces de ces CDI qu'on voudrait qu'on
voudrait créer alors que c'est justement
l'inverse qu'on veut faire on est en
train d'essayer de rechercher des
recettes justement pour financer nos
retraites donc si vous trouvez de la
cohérence dans cette dans cette démarche
faudra peut-être m'expliquer merci
Guillaume Gontard et d'ailleurs on va
voir vos propositions à vous à gauche
sur ce financement du régime des
retraites c'est principalement ce qui va
nous occuper cet après-midi dans les
missile complètement merci retour dans
l'hémistique justement et Chauchard on
dit je les cite un certain nombre
d'exemptions d'assiettes de donne pas
lieu à compensation par le budget de
l'État en effet ces dispositifs pour la
plupart ont été instaurées avant le 13
août 94 or l'obligation de compensation
ne porte que sur les mesures créées
après le 13 août 2014 et donc il n'y
aurait pas d'obligation donc je voudrais
bien avoir votre éclaircissement sur ce
sujet je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur ensuite le 4280
Madame A pour soupe au poli
4279 avant alors non c'est Madame linman
79 c'est moi-même il s'agit donc bien de
proposer un déplafonnement des
cotisations en proposant un des
plafonnement qui ne doivent pas être
inférieur à 2,39 pour les salariés et
4-19 pour les employeurs premièrement
pour les salariés ça ne touchera pas les
salariés dont le revenu mensuel est
inférieur à 366 euros
ne touche pas les salariés les plus
modestes quant à la cotisation employeur
elle elle est quand même très
supportable par les entreprises d'autant
plus que elle contribue quand même
davantage à la redistribution car ce
système de plafonnement est plutôt un
amortisseur à tout esprit de
redistribution
mais par ailleurs monsieur le ministre
vous à votre gouvernement vous répétez à
l'envie nous avons alléger les
cotisations sociales donc ça a permis de
créer des emplois
je voudrais bien savoir sur quelle base
d'analyse de relations de la cause à
effet vous pouvez nous dire ce genre de
choses car quand avait été étudié
l'analyse de l'exonération équivalente
cice le commissaire la Commission et le
comité qui avait dû analyser l'impact
sur l'emploi s'était rendu compte qu'il
était extrêmement modeste parce que la
corrélation ne fait pas la cause il y a
eu un élément une élévation de la
température mondiale avec l'effet de
serre donc ça a créé des emplois puisque
simultanément on a créé des emplois non
essayez donnez-nous les éléments et les
études qui expliquaient réel cause à
effet
si Madame linman le 4278 madame a poursu
poli ou monsieur Bocquet non dans 4278
maintenant on vient de présenter le 4279
merci
effectivement 4278 une nouvelle fois
a-t-elle sizyphe monsieur le ministre
nous allons tenter de vous convaincre
d'augmenter les cotisations sociales
pour certaines catégories afin de
financer non seulement l'équilibre du
régime de retraite existant mais aussi
de permettre de revenir à la retraite à
60 ans en fixant un minimum de retraite
décent garanti à l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes bien entendu cette
perspective fait pousser des cris
d'orfray à tous les défenseurs d'une
orthodoxie libéral je l'entends oui nous
sommes convaincus qu'il existe des
moyens de financer un autre choix de
société un choix de justice sociale et
d'épanouissement humain au terme d'une
carrière professionnelle et surtout ne
nous dit pas que ce soit a été validé
par les élections de 2022 on sait dans
quel contexte ces élection est
intervenue on s'est contre qui monsieur
le Président de la République a été élu
la légitimité proviendrait-elle de
l'alliance de mariage contraint entre le
gouvernement de Monsieur Macron et les
républicains ici
c'est à douter lorsque l'on connaît le
score de ces derniers avec son
présidentielle et au législatives oui il
existe une alternative à votre projet et
des financements existent comme nous
vous le démontrons à maintes reprises
avec l'ensemble des groupes de gauche
durant ce débat le vrai dessin des
auteurs de ce projet et de leur être
relève d'une autre alternative on l'a
évoqué dans j'ai déjà vous prétendez
défendre le régime par répartition avec
cette réforme mais en fait vous poussez
nos concitoyens progressivement ceux qui
ne peuvent en tout cas vers le régime
par capitalisation merci
le 4277 madame Cohen
merci monsieur le Président à l'occasion
de la présentation de cet amendement je
souhaite revenir une nouvelle fois sur
l'enjeu fondamental de notre débat notre
système de retraite va-t-il échapper à
la solidarité pour devenir une
formidable vente pour les fonds de
pension et autres assureurs privés
puisque vous avez réussi à mettre un par
voie d'amendement un rapport sur la
capitalisation si la capacité de
l'utilisation demeure minoritaire en
France et le progresse considérablement
les produits de retraite complémentaires
comptaient fin 2020
14,5 millions d'adhérence soit 4,5
millions de plus en disant le montant
total placé en épargne retraite est
passé de 219 milliards d'euros fin 2016
à 280 milliards en mars 2020 bien sûr en
7,6 milliards d'euros ont été versés au
titre de contrat de retraite
complémentaire contre 338 milliards dans
le cadre du régime par répartition mais
cette part est amenée à progresser de
manière très rapide du fait de la
signature en grand nombre par des jeunes
salariés de contrats de capitalisation
en 2021 20 milliards d'euros d'épargne
retraite ont été collectés ces 27% de
plus qu'en 2021 et 6 fois plus que 10
ans auparavant cela a été déjà dit la
raison est simple a peur de l'avenir
l'incertitude engendrée par les réformes
successives le recul de l'âge du départ
l'allongement des durées de cotisations
qui poussent les plus jeunes vers la
capitalisation il suffit d'avoir des
enfants qui démarrent leur vie
professionnelle connaître des jeunes
dans cette même situation pour
comprendre cette angoisse qui pousse un
sauf qui peut marquer par
l'individualisme notons également que ce
seront surtout les salariés des grandes
entreprises et les contribuables les
plus aisés qui pourront opérer ce
sauvetage bien aléatoire car tributaire
des évolutions des marchés financiers je
vous remercie mais le bruit de fond est
quand même assez gênant
4276 monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les per sur
lesquels les placements explosent
aujourd'hui furent créés par la loi
pacte voter lors du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron il a été lancé en
octobre 2019 ce nouveau per a remplacé
les anciens produits des épargne
retraite individuel ou collectif il
s'agissait tout le monde s'en rappelle
des dispositifs madeleins préfont PERP
ou PERCO ces derniers outils financiers
ne sont plus commercialisés depuis 2020
depuis le lancement la nouvelle formule
un doublement des publicités a été
constaté pour appeler à souscription il
est évident que la perspective d'un
recul de l'âge de la retraite jugé
parfois impossible à atteindre pousse à
cet investissement nous savons toutes et
tous ici que des jeunes récemment
rentrés sur le marché du travail après
des études plus ou moins longues nous
pourrons pas espérer un taux plein avant
68 69 voir 70 ans il faut donc trouver
coûte que coûte des nouveaux moyens pour
permettre de partir à la retraite à un
HD 100 en bonne santé coûte que coûte
pour les travailleuses et travailleurs
concernés salariés ou libéraux mais
aussi coucou Decout pour la société car
ce développement considérable des
assurances privées se fait bien entendu
au détriment de la solidarité au cœur du
système de répartition principe de
solidarité fondée sur les cotisations
sociales pourtant le risque est grand
car chacune et chacun sait que les
placements financiers sont incertains il
suffit de se remémorer la crise des
subprimes aux États-Unis entraînant un
crack mondial et la disparition du jour
au lendemain pour les Américains de leur
épargne capitalisée le PER c'est aussi
une arme terrible contre la solidarité
du fait du plafond très élevé de
déduction fiscale et tout le monde sait
ici que les couches populaires ne
pourront pas la peindre je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur gay
le 4275 madame sont actuellement en
train de débattre de hausse de
cotisation vieillesse sur les eaux
salaires dans ce débat cet après-midi
sur la réforme des retraites alors vous
entendez toute une série de prise de
parole de sénateurs communistes alors
pourquoi toute cette série et bien parce
que les générateurs communistes ont
déposé 19 amendements quasiment
identiques en changeant quelques
pourcentages pour augmenter les
cotisations vieillesse sur les salaires
au-delà de 366 euros par mois et donc
les sénateurs communistes s'offrent avec
ses 19 amendements
identiques une tribune pour s'exprimer
notamment sur
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
dans les politiques économiques ces
dernières années puisque on explique la
règle à chaque amendement il y a une
prise de parole de l'auteur de
l'amendement de 2 minutes donc vous
faites le calcul laissez un temps commis
sont en train de s'offrir des dizaines
de minutes de prise de parole dans ce
débat sur la réforme des retraites et
face à ces sénateurs communistes vous
avez toute la droite et le centre du
Sénat qui écoute silencieusement sans
répondre pour ne pas perdre de temps
leurs collègues communistes voilà je
vous laisse suivre la révolution de ces
débats dans le système de répartition en
augmentant un certain nombre de
cotisations notamment sur les plus hauts
revenus puisqu'il s'agit comme je l'ai
précisé du plafond sécurité sociale qui
est à 366 euros mensuels le les
cotisations que nous évoquons ne sont
pas de nature à remettre en cause
considérablement le niveau de vie de nos
concitoyens qui seraient concernés par
ces légères augmentations de cotisations
mais cela permettrait de d'essayer de
rétablir une certaine égalité au sens où
aujourd'hui un cadre à dans notre pays
en moyenne un peu plus de 6 ans
d'espérance de vie par rapport à un
ouvrier et que donc faire cotiser un
petit peu plus les plus hauts revenus
qui sont souvent les métiers de
l'encadrement par rapport au salaire les
plus faibles nous permettrait de
rétablir un peu de justice je vous
remercie
merci Madame Bolland le 4274 madame a
poursaut poli
merci monsieur le Président une nouvelle
fois je vais vous faire la démonstration
du caractère purement dogmatique des
choix gouvernementaux concernant
l'avenir du régime de retraite les
chiffres sont là des moyens existent non
seulement pour refuser le recul de l'âge
de du départ à la retraite mais aussi
pour revenir à la retraite à 60 ans à
taux plein cette réforme ni juste ni
nécessaire est imposée par les marchés
il n'est pas compliqué de comprendre que
ces marchés détenteurs en partie du
devenir de la dette de notre pays exerce
une forme de chantage via les
constitutions européennes en exigeant
contre leur bienveillance la
privatisation massive de l'économie y
compris l'économie sociale
reculer l'âge de la retraite c'est faire
le bonheur de la capitalisation en
poussant ce qu'ils peuvent acheter des
années de leur vie à la retraite en
bonne santé auprès des établissements
financiers aujourd'hui le régime est en
équilibre monsieur le ministre vous ne
pouvez pas le nier les scénarios les
plus pessimistes du per envisage un
déficit de 12 milliards d'euros en 2027
et de 13,5 à l'horizon 2023 rien ne
justifiait la précipitation actuelle à
coup de 47,1 vous avez provoqué la crise
vous avez tendu la société et provoquer
l'affrontement social et politique c'est
amendement parmi les autres fait le
choix d'une augmentation ciblée des
cotisations sociales sachez que leur
augmentation de 0,8 comblerait le
déficit précipité de 12,7 milliards mais
bien d'autres levier existe pour
financer une grande avancée sociale pas
au service des financiers je vous
remercie merci le 4273 qui le présente
Madame linman
oui chers collègues notre amendement est
un moment est un amendement de repli
puisque nous sommes toujours dans le
déplafonnement des cotisations mais nous
avons baissé un tout petit peu le niveau
de ce déplafonnement tant pour les
salariés dont je vous rappelle que seuls
qui gagnent plus de 366 euros serait
concernés et d'autre part pour les
entreprises je voudrais quand même
rappeler que pourquoi ces propositions
ces glenus c'est les recettes l'enjeu
c'est la justice dans les cotisations
pour assurer la retraite plutôt que de
d'arriver à allonger la durée légale
auxquels pour avoir accès à cette
retraite or vous vous
tirez toujours un trait sur tout
hypothèse de nouvelles retraites ne
croyez pas que nos concitoyens qui ne
sont évidemment pas des fanatiques de
l'impôt et du prélèvement ne soit aussi
O vous l'imaginez à cette hypothèse car
des récents sondages ont clairement
montré qu'il préférait nettement une
hausse les cotisations dont je vous
rappelle que dans le cas présent ne
touche que un certain niveau de salaire
plutôt que ces deux ans de travail
supplémentaires ils envoient les
conséquences et la dureté et il préfère
une légère augmentation des prélèvements
mais indépendamment de ça il y a des
zones grises de de secs de rémunération
qui n'ont pas de prélèvement et plus
vous êtes en situation de ne pas faire
cotiser l'intéressement les primes etc
plus vous vous théorisez le fait que le
salaire qui est quand même le cœur de la
rémunération ne doit pas être augmenté
et vous multipliez les primes et enfin
multipliées il y a quand même que 700
000 personnes qui ont touché la prime
Macron quand on voit la masse des
salariés c'est quand même très loin
merci le
4272 monsieur gay
non non le 4272 le 73 vient d'être
présenté
je vais vous faire plaisir monsieur le
Président je vais défendre le 4272 par
cet amendement nous proposons d'inscrire
à spécifiquement dans l'article
l241-3 du code de la sécurité sociale un
nouveau taux de cotisations sociales
nous proposons que celui-ci soit fixé
premièrement à 0,40 % pour les salariés
et 1,90 pour les employeurs sur la part
des revenus inférieurs au plafond
mentionné au présent article et
deuxièmement à 2,42% pour les salariés
et à 4,72 pour les employeurs sur la
part des revenus strictement supérieurs
au même plafond cette proposition
s'inscrit avec d'autres dans notre
volonté de démontrer qu'il existe
d'autres moyens pour assurer pérenniser
le régime de retraite pareil partition
que celui de reculer l'âge du départ à
la retraite c'est-à-dire de voler deux
années d'une retraite en bonne santé si
utile à la société plutôt que d'aller
chercher l'argent là où il est chez les
plus riches
je profite de cet instant pour vous
rappeler que l'annulation des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
soit près de 85 milliards d'euros prévus
pour 2023 rapporterait de suite
18,4 milliards pour la branche
vieillesse sans compter les économies
pour le budget de l'État qui est
actuellement compense ces exonérations
augmenter les cotisations sociales
supprimer les exonérations indus
participerez à les forums importants
pour revenir à la retraite à 60 ans et
porter à 2000 euros brut la retraite
minimum réforme qui exigerait 100
milliards d'euros par an l'instauration
d'une cotisation pour les retraites sur
les dividendes nets 50 milliards d'euros
en 2021 à hauteur de 28% comme pour les
salaires rapporterait 14 milliards
d'euros et une hausse de 5% des salaires
dans le privé et 5% du point d'indice ne
fonctionnaires rapporterait
respectivement 9 milliards et un
milliard et demi pour la branche
retraite voici quelques pistes que nous
donnons et au ministre et à la droite
sénatoriale
merci Monsieur Gaëlle
4271 madame Brulin merci monsieur le
Président notre collègue Marie-Noël
linman a eu raison de rappeler que la
plupart de nos concitoyens qui refusent
de voir l'allongement de la retraite de
l'âge de départ en retraite à 64 ans
lorsqu'ils sont interrogés y compris
dans le contexte de pouvoir d'achat
particulièrement abîmé que nous
connaissons pense et préférerait voir
une augmentation de leur cotisation
c'est précisément ce que nous proposons
et encore une fois nous voulons c'est ce
relèvement du niveau de cotisation
minime sur les contribuables les plus
aisés qui n'en ressentiraient quasiment
pas le contrecoup sur leur vie
quotidienne
d'autant qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
à nombreux à investir dans des
instruments financiers de capitalisation
et encore une fois nous proposons de le
réinjecter ces sommes assez colossales
dans le système de solidarité il faut
savoir par exemple que les nouveaux
plans épargne retraite que nous étions
depuis plusieurs interventions qui ont
été lancées il y a deux ans représentent
plus de la moitié des cotisations
retraite supplémentaires selon l'adresse
la Direction de la recherche des études
de l'évaluation et des statistiques à
annoncé que cette hausse explique
essentiellement par le développement du
PER individuel dont les versements
représentent près des trois quarts des
cotisations sur les dispositifs
individuels 73% pour être précise fin
2020 près fin 2021 pardon près de 20
milliards d'euros de cotisations ont été
collectés dans le cadre du contrat de
retraite supplémentaire un montant en
hausse de 27% en courant par rapport à
la fin 2020 la collecte par les nouveaux
per dépend du type de contrat individuel
d'entreprises collectif ou d'entreprises
obligatoires et ils ont enregistré
respectivement 8 milliards 2,2 milliards
et 970 millions d'euros de cotisations
voilà qui pourrait venir abonder
utilement le régime par répartition je
vous remercie
le
4270 monsieur Bocquet monsieur le
Président mon intervention vaudra à
présentation des deux amendements qui
viennent de 42 70 et le 42 69 comme quoi
il ne faut jamais désespérer du groupe
communiste
depuis les semaines le gouvernement
argue que la réforme demeure absolument
indispensable incontournable avec une
approche budgétaire et financière
démographique nous dit-on le système de
retraite serait déficitaire d'environ 18
milliards d'euros par an et nous ne
serions pas à l'équilibre avant le
milieu des années 2030
pourtant nous souhaitons rappeler ici
que dès 2020 le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui a servi de boussole à
beaucoup d'entre nous nuancé ce constat
je cite le système de retraite n'est pas
menacé et le déficit serait de l'ordre
de 0,3% du PIB maximum à l'horizon 2025
c'est un niveau qui n'a rien
d'alarmement vous en conviendrez les
dernières études du corps vont plus loin
les dépenses de retraite ont été revues
à la baisse les pensions représentaient
14% du PIB avant la crise les études
indiquent qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
autour de 13,7%. la nuance de donc -03%
est important d'autant que les
trajectoires indiquent que la part des
retraites dans le PIB continuera de
baisser dans les années à venir dans ces
conditions nous proposons une solution
pour remédier aux déficit temporaire par
la création d'une contribution
additionnelle des plafonnée sur
l'ensemble des revenus d'activités dont
le taux serait de 1,4% pour les salariés
et de 3,4% pour les employeurs cette
solution ne pénaliserait ni les basses
salaires ni les travailleurs en deçà
d'un Rev enu mensuel de 366 euros ni les
personnes assujetties je vous remercie
merci le 4346
4346 qui représente
il est défendu il est défendu le 434
voilà retour en salle des conférences
ici au Sénat la salle qui joue cette
l'hémicycle je suis avec Olivier Hainaut
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
centriste et vous êtes le chef de fil de
votre groupe sur la réforme des
retraites au Sénat un mot sur ce qui se
joue ce qui se déroule dans l'hémicycle
cette prise de parole des sénateurs
communistes qui proposent des
alternatives au financement de la
réforme des retraites mais qui donc
aussi monopolise la parole c'est le
retour à une forme et bien d'obstruction
cordiale comme on l'avait vu ce week-end
oui ou c'est ce que les Américains
appellent la flibusterie la fille
bustery parlementaire je reste très
longtemps voilà alors même des des
ouvrages
dans le respect dans la cordialité mais
considérons que en termes de gestion du
temps on pourrait mieux faire alors il y
a des débats qui sont intéressants
ma conviction d'ailleurs c'est que cette
question de l'emploi des seniors elle
est centrale il y a la question des
femmes la pénibilité l'emploi des
seniors et que effectivement
il faut que la société française se
mobilise pour que il y a une quantité de
travail supplémentaire pour financer ce
système de retraite par répartition et
ça passe par l'emploi des seniors parce
que même avant même cette réforme des
retraites l'emploi des seniors est
beaucoup trop faible dans notre pays
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire on a un
taux d'emploi des seniors des 55 64 ans
seulement 56% en 2021 en France c'est
l'un des plus bas en Europe qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de dans ce contexte
de ce vote sur un CDI seigneur du Sénat
c'est avec ce genre d'outils qu'on peut
lutter c'est pas un peu petit bras
alors il y a des risques qu'on a un
doute mais faut faire quelque chose et
il faut une mobilisation des partenaires
sociaux moi petite personnel c'est aussi
exprimé par Jean-Marie verlanberg on
préférerait une prime qu'une exonération
mais enfin ça relèverait de l'article 40
vous savez c'est la mécanique
parlementaire
bon ok pour l'exonération mais là tout à
l'heure je vais proposer un amendement
parce qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait des
phénomène et et dans cet amendement il
est proposé que
[Musique]
non seulement des 57 ans mais surtout
que si le salarié ne va pas au bout
c'est-à-dire si la entreprise ne
respecte pas son engagement et bien le
remboursement des exonérations est
automatique parce que il faut faire en
sorte que les engagements soient tenus
notamment par rapport à cet emploi des
seniors voilà
ça c'est vraiment une des clés de la
société française cette question de
l'emploi des seniors alors est-ce que du
coup on ne met pas la charrue avant les
bœufs en décalant l'âge de départ à la
retraite alors qu'il y a ce mauvais taux
d'emploi des seniors est-ce que la pas
fait le faire la loi travail avec des
mesures en faveur de l'emploi des
seniors avant de décaler l'âge en bas on
l'a dit bien évidemment
cette réforme des retraites elle est
indispandables mais le calendrier est
moyen la loi travail d'ailleurs on nous
dit qu'elle arrivera après bon bah si
elle arrivera après on va s'en
occuper mais c'est sûr que on l'a dit
dans la discussion générale au lendemain
d'une du covid la société française est
fatiguée et épuisée il faut se
réinterroger sur la valeur travail parce
qu'il y a pas de grand pays sans sans
une acceptation de la valeur de travail
or un sondage récent montre que cette
valeur travail est en crise et donc
naturellement c'est une question clé
pour l'avenir du pays pas seulement pour
la retraite aussi pour les plus jeunes
le management plus
est incapable de se former pour changer
de métier quand il le désirent quand il
en a envie quand il a l'involté ça c'est
la clé la question de la valeur travail
dans notre société j'ai une dernière
question on arrive à la fin de cette
interview il m'en reste peut-être deux
questions en vrai dire mais déjà une sur
le financement de la réforme on se
souvient qu'à l'automne vous aviez parlé
de taxer les super profils des
entreprises est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous pourriez remettre sur la
table à l'occasion de se payer FSR non
la taxation des super profits on l'a
proposé notre groupe par la voie d'Hervé
Marseille mais c'était pour la question
de l'énergie on va pas le mettre à
toutes les sauces d'autant plus que
c'est quelque chose qui peut varier là
on est donc dans une volonté de de
pérenniser le le système de retraite et
donc ça ne conviendrait pas ce serait de
la démagogie de proposer ça toutes les
sauces et nous on se refuse à cette
démagogie j'ai l'impression donc en vue
de cette mobilisation qui a lieu demain
comment est-ce que cette France à
l'arrêt tel que le veulent l'Inter
syndical cela peut avoir un écho dans le
débat parlementaire notamment de demain
après-midi et demain soir puisqu'on
parle maintenant de plus plus en une
séance de nuit demain au Sénat alors moi
je vais vous dire ma conviction profonde
mais c'était avant cette réforme des
retraites c'est qu'il faut refonder et
rénover le paritarisme moi quand je vois
tous les leaders syndicaux et un front
syndical ça me trouble alors maintenant
le 20 est tiré il faut le boire sur
cette réforme mais la refondation du
paritarisme me paraît une exigence et je
pense qu'il y a un homme-clé dans ce
pays c'est c'est le secrétaire général
le CFDT monsieur berger il faut
absolument que l'on réhabilite le le
paritarisme parce que sans dialogue
social et bien il y a des confrontations
il faut apaiser ce pays et ça passe par
une refondation du paritarisme et donc
Olivier Hainaut vous le dites il y a eu
un doute dans votre esprit lorsqu'il y a
eu front commun de l'intersey syndicale
cette réforme sur le fait même que vous
centriste vous pouvez vous puissiez la
voter
naturellement on peut pas moi je peux
pas dire je peux pas dire que je suis
pas troublé par cette question le
ça n'aurait pas de sens moi les les
éléments de langage la certitude tout ça
je j'ai trop vu j'ai trop vu des gens
qui vous savez musclés montrer leurs
muscles et puis après pouvez changer
d'avis non bien sûr moi je pense que le
dialogue syndical le paritarisme c'est
la clé c'était la clé pour hier c'est la
clé pour aujourd'hui et c'est la clé
pour demain et bien merci merci Olivier
nous merci c'est pour être sincérité au
micro de Public Sénat merci merci
pour c'était énorme donc là en
l'occurrence là en l'occurrence vous
retirez plusieurs dizaines voire une
cinquantaine d'euros à des salariés dans
un moment d'inflation on sait que
certains nombre de françaises sont en
difficulté donc je suis pas évidemment
en accord ensuite il y a d'autres
amendements effectivement où c'est des
augmentations de cotisation salariale
qui démarre à 29 00 euros de salaire net
de 1900 euros de salaire net c'est ça
veut dire que vous touchez un quart des
salariés alors effectivement c'est ceux
qui gagnent plus de 2900 euros moi
simplement j'ai l'air sur un point vous
avez aujourd'hui 10% des Français qui
payent 70% de l'impôt sur le revenu
vous avez des Français qui travaillent
qui travaillent dur qui peuvent être
dans ce niveau de salaire qui voit
beaucoup d'argent public qui est investi
dépensé pour accompagner des Français
qui ne travaillent pas moi alerte aussi
sur les classements yannes françaises
qui aujourd'hui ont le sentiment qu'on
leur demande toujours à elle les efforts
pour financer des mesures qui ne les
concernent jamais donc moi je suis en
désaccord avec cette ligne là mais c'est
un beau débat c'est un beau débat je
pense que ces amendements entraîneraient
soit une destruction d'emplois soit une
destruction de pouvoir d'achat et dans
les deux cas j'y suis défavorable
maintenant pour répondre à deux
interventions précises et spécifiques
monsieur gay vous m'avez interrogé sur
les exonérations de cotisations
l'état compense aujourd'hui 70 milliards
d'euros d'exonération de cotisations
sociales qui ont eu lieu sous tous les
gouvernements je citais tout à l'heure
l'exemple sur le gouvernement de
François Hollande avec 25 milliards
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
je pourrais citer un gouvernement auquel
vous participiez pas vous monsieur gay
mais en tout cas les communistes Lionel
Jospin il a doublé l'exonération non
mais il était pas au gouvernement madame
assassy il était il était encore plus
jeune comme moi mais les communistes
participaient à l'époque à la gauche
plurielle Lionel Jospin son gouvernement
a doublé le montant des exonérations de
cotisations sociales elles sont passées
de 10 à 20 milliards sous cette
législatures et l'Insee c'était en
parallèle des 35 heures c'était en
parallèle 35 heures effectivement
l'Insee l'Insee a estimé à 300 000
emplois créés via ses exonérations
sociales qui ont augmenté donc il y a
ses 70 milliards de compensations de
l'État à la sécurité sociale et je vous
confirme qu'il n'est pas du tout prévu
de revenir sur ces cette compensation
par l'État c'était votre question
deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
revenir et j'en finirai là monsieur le
Président c'est madame lilleman vous
avez parlé de la prime Macron et vous
avez indiqué que 700000 salariés
seulement avait perçu la prime Macron je
viens de publier les chiffres 2022 c'est
5 millions 500000 salariés qui ont
bénéficié de la prime Macron 5 millions
500000 et pas des salariés dans des
grandes entreprises ou des
multinationales 2 millions de salariés
qui ont reçu la prime sont dans des
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés et
là où le montant de la prime Macron est
le plus élevé c'est dans les TPE puisque
c'est 1000 euros de prime Macron en
moyenne donc on n'est pas du tout dans
les chiffres que vous avez donné au
contraire c'est un très bel outil de
partage de la valeur dans l'entreprise
évidemment qu'on soutient avis
défavorable sur tous ces amendements
donc un double avis des favorable alors
j'ai avant que tout passion au vote j'ai
un certain nombre de demandes de
d'explications de vote madame linman
première réaction celle liée aux
déclarations de notre rapporteur
madame la rapporteur la thèse selon
laquelle en augmentant les cotisations
raisonnablement nos propositions sont
pas énormes des cotisations
patronales de retraite onirait à la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
permettez-moi de vous dire que ça fait
partie des ronrons qu'on répète sans
preuve la preuve si je puis dire inverse
et ben justement
150 milliards dans le de baisse de
cotisation et le et le déficit
commercial se creuse pourquoi parce que
la stratégie il y a plus d'un peu de
stratégie industrielle parce qu'on a
laissé faire le dumping social parce
qu'on a laissé augmenter le prix de
l'énergie à cause du marché européen
tous les éléments de compétitivité
historique de la France vous les avez
laissés affaiblir par des choix
européens et il vous reste plus qu'une
seule chose c'est d'essayer de baisser
le entre guillemets ou du travail et ça
ne marche pas ça ne marche pas il faut
des politiques industrielles il faut
mais c'est pas selon moi la balance
commerciale on est tous d'accord pour
qu'on s'était qu'elle est abyssale bon
donc la réalité c'est que ce n'est pas
le noeud de notre la parole linman si
des collègues des républicains veulent
s'inscrire c'est tout à fait possible
mais oui surtout
répondre aux collègues ne manquez pas
cet argumentation si nécessaire à notre
départ
de deuxième sujet oui notre nous
demandons une augmentation de l'assiette
de l'assiette des cotisants pas du
niveau massif des cotisants alors
évidemment parfois on élargissant
l'assiette on tombe sur un nombre il
faut conclure mais mon collègue Fabien
gay ou d'autres vous expliqueront
pourquoi merci Madame Poncet Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors
préalablement quand même je voudrais
adresser à Monsieur Attal une supplique
qu'il sait c'est provoquée
et il devrait d'ailleurs
vous voulez qu'on aille plus vite si
vous provoquez on va aller plus
lentement et notamment je le rappelle
que le la décision de l'intersyndical
mais je vois que l'Inter syndicale vous
l'a pas envoyé donc je vais lui demander
de l'envoyer ce termina par le souhait
qu'à partir de demain on mette la France
à l'arrêt mettre la France à l'arrêt ce
n'est pas la France à genoux c'est la
France à genoux vous vous en occupez
donc je voudrais donc ah oui
David dans
l'amendement 42 83 modifié
et donc je voudrais revenir sur le
problème justement des cotisations
j'ai vu monsieur Attal que vous êtes
attentif au sondage alors je vais vous
en donner un 66% c'est à dire de tiers
des 18 à 24 ans jeune actifs sont
favorables à l'augmentation de les
cotisations plutôt enfin comme levier
plutôt que le levier que vous activez
vous l'allongement de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite et cette
tranche d'âge qui est favorable à deux
tiers à l'augmentation des cotisations
ce n'est pas une tranche d'âge favorisée
sur le plan du pouvoir d'achat donc ça
serait bien que vous ne parliez pas en
au nom des salariés quant à ce pouvoir
d'achat et je termine aussi sur le fait
que pour ce qui est de la compétitivité
alors là bon c'est peut-être un peu plus
votre sujet nous n'avons pas le même
diagnostic ce n'est pas le coup du
travail qui pèse sur la compétitivité
c'est le coût du capital quand les
dividendes oui quand les dividendes sont
10% du PIB quand les quand pour avoir
des profits on a une stratégie dénitaire
de d'investissement
oui c'est le coup du capital merci
plombe la compétitivité merci Madame
Poncet Monge la parole à Monsieur à
Madame briquet pardon madame briquet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
les inégalités se creusent la réforme
des retraites proposées par le
gouvernement va contribuer à renforcer
ses inégalités le prétexte financier mis
en avant par le gouvernement n'est pas
crédible il existe en effet de
nombreuses sources de financement qui
permettraient de ne pas pénaliser à
nouveau les travailleurs et les
travailleuses tout en renforçant une
solidarité largement mise à mal depuis
plusieurs années mais votre retraite
monsieur le ministre n'est pas une
réforme de notre système de retraite
c'est une mesure d'économie que vous
avez choisie délibérément un arbitrage
économique Bruno Le Maire ne s'en est
jamais caché d'ailleurs c'est le moyen
choisi pour envoyer un signe à Bruxelles
et afficher ainsi une réduction globale
du déficit que ce gouvernement lui-même
aggravé
mais aussi et surtout pour suivre sa
politique d'allègement fiscal pour les
plus aisés et le désarmement fiscal de
notre pays belle manière de dire aux
Français les plus modestes payer et
payer toujours contentez-vous du peu de
service public qui résiste encore et
cerise sur le gâteau travailler et
cotiser deux ans de plus
merci Madame Riquet la parole à Monsieur
Chaumier
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'ai aucune leçon à
recevoir en terme d'équilibre des
comptes publics d'un gouvernement qui a
à ce point au détérioré ces comptes qui
est à ce point mille le déficit de la
balance commerciale au zénith et qui
maintenant plonge le budget de chaque
Français dans une grande difficulté nous
avons toujours dit que effectivement il
fallait regarder comment mieux
équilibrer le régime des retraites mais
le problème c'est là où c'est le cœur du
problème cette discussion c'est que
toutes les pistes relatives au
cotisations vous les écartez donc
évidemment vous utilisez quel levier le
plus injuste le report de las légal de
deux ans celui qui pénalise le plus les
plus modestes et les travailleurs en
situation les plus les plus pénibles
madame la rapporteur nous dit il faut
pas tenter à la compétitivité économique
des entreprises oui mais il y a des
exonérations qui n'ont aucun impact sur
l'emploi le Conseil d'analyse économique
l'a dit et seule là non plus quand on
propose de les supprimer vous ne voulez
pas pourquoi
les quatre entreprises il y a 4
entreprises françaises qui elles seules
l'année dernière on fait 64 milliards de
bénéfices
64 milliards pour quatre entreprises
nous avons proposé aussi de regarder
comment on pouvait les mettre à
contribution sans je vous rassure les
plonger dans un déficit abyssal et bien
vous refusez aussi donc c'est une ligne
idéologique que vous avez qui est
respectable mais vous dites on ne
touchera pas au cotisations on ne
touchera pas à ce que les entreprises
payent donc évidemment à partir de ce
moment-là et équilibrer les comptes bah
vous utilisez des leviers qui ne pèsent
que sur les salariés et que sur les
salariés les plus modestes c'est un
juste et nous on soutiendra ses
amendements
merci Monsieur chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président je vois que
vous êtes tenté de réagir de répondre et
c'est normal parce qu'il y a une vraie
confrontation entre nous sur ce sujet là
sur la vision que vous avez d'ailleurs
madame la rapporteur vous parlez en
permanence de charge et c'est un
supportable ce ne sont pas des charges
et ça a été très même le ministre ne dit
pas Charles d'ailleurs Eddy cotisation
j'ai relevé mais c'est des cotisations
effectivement qui participent à notre
système de protection sociale pour
protéger les gens contre les accidents
de la vie c'est du salaire différé ce ne
sont pas des charges donc déjà employer
les bons mots parler de parler de
cotisations d'ailleurs c'est pas vous
pouvez intervenir vous inquiétez pas
monsieur monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs
et ça a été très bien rappelé par mon
collègue jaumier vous utilisez
effectivement la variable la plus
injuste celle du relèvement de las vegal
de départ de retraite à 64 ans et par
contre on vous avait au moins une CO que
vous suivez avec abnégation depuis 6 ans
c'est vous ne souhaitez pas
effectivement que les plus fortunés que
les gens qui possèdent le plus ne
participent pas la solidarité nationale
ça vous avez cette cohérence là c'est
pour ça que nous soutiendrons bien
évidemment cette amendement parce que la
solidarité c'est de la faire peser à
ceux qui ont de plus mais depuis 6 ans
vous ne faites que diminuer les
cotisations vous ne faites que diminuer
les impôts des plus fortunés mais il y a
de quoi enragé il y a de quoi mettre en
colère les Français et les Françaises et
vous le diront massivement à nouveau
dans la rue demain pour que vous
retiriez cette réforme profondément
injuste et brutale vis-à-vis des plus
démunis de ce pays
madame madame Bruno
merci monsieur le président
nous sommes en train de débattre de
quelque chose qui me semble extrêmement
sérieux et qu'il faudrait qu'on le fasse
de manière approfondie on est dans un
pays qui refuse absolument massivement
de travailler deux ans de plus et qui va
le redire avec force et encore plus
massivement demain à partir de là ou
bien vous vous entêtez à aller dans
cette voie et je ne sais pas où ça nous
conduira parce que tout a montré que
vous avez beau défendre argumenter ce
projet de loi ça met toujours plus de
monde dans la rue plus de monde en
colère nous nous ouvrons le débat sur
d'autres possibilités de financer la
retraite parce que monsieur le ministre
je trouve je vous trouve d'une mauvaise
foi caractérisée
nous n'avons jamais dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème de financement nous
n'avons fait que redire ce que dit le
corps lui-même c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
dérapage incontrôlé qui nous met en
péril dans ces toutes prochaines années
mais par contre bien sûr qui a des
sources de financement à trouver parce
que réforme après réforme
c'est ce sont c'est le niveau de pension
de nos concitoyens qui a diminué qui
risque de diminuer encore
considérablement donc si nous voulons
assurer à chacun une retraite digne oui
il va falloir chercher des sources de
financement nous disons aussi que il
faut tenter de retourner vers la
retraite à 60 ans parce que quand on
voit le taux d'emploi actuel entre 60 et
62 ans on voit bien qu'il y a un sujet
qui en a qui ne peuvent plus bosser dans
ces âges-là et bien donc ça va
nécessiter d'aller chercher des sources
de financement vous à vos propositions
diverses que nous faisons notamment sur
la cotisation vous ne répondez de
manière obsessionnelle que par
exonération de cotisation et recule de
l'âge nous demandons à ouvrir ce débat
nous le devons aux Français je crois
qu'il nous attendent là-dessus et que ce
débat de société aurait un très grand
intérêt pour chacun merci Madame Bruno
la parole est à Monsieur broyé
merci monsieur le Président non non vous
n'aurez pas d'indice merci monsieur le
ministre vous évoquez le déséquilibre
nous n'augions pas qu'il y a un problème
de recettes et même nous faisons
beaucoup de propositions mais vous
refusez avec un peu d'entêtement il faut
le dire d'envisager cet aspect de
l'équation vous cheminez toujours dans
la même direction finalement pour vous
les cotisations ça n'est pas bien mais
il y a d'ailleurs d'autres possibilités
par exemple le fond de réserve des
retraites pourrait bien être alimentée
par une partie des 56,9 milliards de
dividendes versés l'année dernière
record d'Europe quand même détenu par
notre pays alors face à cette situation
la nécessité de trouver des recettes
mais que les communistes ont dans un
souci je dois dire très détaillé de
rechercher le compromis ont été chercher
plusieurs points d'équilibre possible et
acceptable par notre hémicycle
monsieur le ministre vous refusez donc
cette solution proposée par nos
collègues mais vous vous en choisissez
une qui est de prendre deux ans de la
vie de nos concitoyens vous êtes jeune
vous ne voyez sans doute pas la valeur
du temps qu'il reste à vivre pour les
gens plus âgés mais permettez à un jeune
sénateur comme vous l'avez souligné qui
voit cependant la ligne d'arrivée plus
proche sans doute que la vôtre de vous
dire qu'il faut que les gens aient du
temps pour vivre pour aimer pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants de leurs
petits-enfants et prendre deux ans c'est
l'injustice la plus grande que nous
puissions faire et ces millions de
personnes qui demain seront dans la rue
vous le diront vous le répéteront ils
veulent vivre et notre pays on a besoin
dans la vie associative dans l'aide aux
enfants dans l'aide aux parents
dépendants et puis simplement pour leur
permettre de vivre parce qu'on a aussi
le droit de vivre et de ne rien faire
merci
Monsieur Assouline
oui j'ai entendu deux arguments de du
ministre le premier c'est celui là c'est
quand même incroyable que vous êtes en
train de nous dire en gros
que prendre deux ans de la vie des gens
c'est quelque chose oui prendre deux ans
de la vie prendre
c'est prendre deux ans de la vie
autrement qu'au travail de ceux qui ont
trimé toute leur vie en attendant aussi
ce moment où ils vont pouvoir faire
autre chose
et vous nous le mettez en balance comme
si c'est un coup c'est une régression et
vous nous donnez l'exemple de Lionel
Jospin enfin le problème c'est que
Lionel Jospin quand il fait des
exonérations c'est pour soulager
l'économie parce que il crée un progrès
social historique pour les travailleurs
qui sont les 35 heures là vous vous
dites que il ne faut pas de comme si
c'était inconnu le fait que vous
proposez au cœur de votre effort une
régression sociale historique encore
avec deux ans de recul de l'âge légal de
la retraite et puis il y a
la situation c'est à dire le corps nous
dit qu'il y a une maîtrise il ne dit pas
effectivement qu'il n'y aura pas de
problème avec la démographie actuelle de
financement des retraites à terme mais
il dit qu'aujourd'hui c'est maîtrisé et
on entend aujourd'hui monsieur Véran
venir nous dire
c'est que le gouvernement a d'autres
urgences que la question de la réforme
des retraites alors pourquoi au moment
où il y a l'inflation où les gens
n'arrivent plus à vivre et pas seulement
ce qui était déjà pauvre mais les
classes moyennes qui basculent pourquoi
dans ce moment où les salaires restent
bas et face à l'inflation régresse le
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi dans ce moment
cette réforme précipitée pour encore
plus attaquer au même pourquoi insuline
merci Madame Cohen
il est 15h27 nous sommes en direct sur
l'antenne de public Sénas si vous nous
rejoignons à faire un point avec notre
journaliste Alexandre Poussard rebonjour
Alexandre vous êtes toujours en tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle dites-nous un
peu où nous en sommes en ce lundi
après-midi et bien Quentin on est en
train de suivre un débat sur les hausses
de cotisation pour équilibrer les
finances de notre régime des retraites
alors que les communistes ont proposé
toute une série à d'amendement une
petite vingtaine d'amendements pour
augmenter les cotisations des employeurs
et puis aussi des hauts salaires
notamment les salaires au-dessus de 3700
euros mensuels les sénateurs qui
défendent ces mesures pour demander un
effort au plus aisé et aux entreprises
afin d'équilibrer ce régime et de ne pas
forcément demander au travers modeste de
travailler plus longtemps alors en face
le gouvernement a aimé à émy un avis
défavorable à toutes ces propositions
d'amendement le Miss des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal estime que cela va encore
frapper elle est classe alors qu'il a
avancé un chiffre en 10% de la
population française paye 70 %
actuellement de l'impôt sur le revenu
donc selon lui il ne faudrait pas
frapper davantage les classes moyennes
et puis du côté de la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat la rapporteur
général Elisabeth Doisneau la cicatrice
centriste a estimé que c'est hausse de
cotisations des employeurs elle est
encore alourdir les charges des
entreprises et diminuer leur
compétitivité alors que la balance
commerciale est déjà déficitaire en
France il y a beaucoup plus
d'importation que d'exportation dans
notre pays donc pour elle il ne faut pas
diminuer la compétitivité économique
française oui alors Alex a parlé
représentants de la Commission et du
gouvernement sur le banc on entend très
peu la droite c'est uniquement des
prises de parole de sénateur soit du
groupe communiste du groupe écologiste
ou du groupe socialiste n'est-ce pas et
oui on est un petit peu sur un monologue
de gauche cet après-midi au Sénat alors
que les communistes ont déposé un je le
disais une petite vingtaine
d'amendements ça leur a donné déjà
beaucoup de temps de prise de parole
pour défendre ses amendements les
socialistes les écologistes arguments
aussi dans cette explication de vote et
effectivement on entend aucun sénateur
les républicains prendre la parole il y
a certainement des consignes venues de
la présidente du groupe LR au Sénat pour
ne pas répondre à ce que certains
appellent l'obstruction cordiale de la
gauche sénatoriale mais je peux vous
dire que dans l'hémicycle est bien
laissé à terre et l'air très pin
d'impatience de répondre à ces arguments
notamment sur la compétitivité et les
charges sociales des entreprises on
entend parfois dans les métiers et bien
un brouhaha venu de la droite car et
bien les sénateurs répondent
interpellent les sénateurs LR
interpellent leurs collègues de gauche
mais sans prendre la parole au micro car
et bien le temps tourne et il reste
encore
2987 amendements à examiner et la droite
sénatoriale voudrait aller beaucoup plus
vite merci Alexandre merci pour tous ces
explications retour au direct dans
l'hémicycle laisser la sénatrice
communiste et Cathy pour ce polica à la
parole
à notre pays en livrons secteur privé la
gestion de nos fins de vie mais
objectivement il n'est pas en danger car
des solutions existent des moyens de
financement existent vous faites peur à
notre peuple peur aux salariés vous
l'inquiétez pour jeter ce qui est auront
de mal les moyens dans les bras de la
capitale
oui des solutions existent nous le
cessons de vous le répéter en mettant à
contribution les dividendes en assumant
l'égalité salariale homme-femme pourquoi
alors refusez-vous de faire participer
le capital au redressement de la
protection sociale vous faites un choix
politique qui n'est pas celui de
l'intérêt général
oui nous sommes et nous le voyons bien
dans ce débat projet contre projet
pourquoi ne débattez-vous pas de ce
chiffre 5 % d'augmentation des salaires
dans le privé ces 9 milliards de
cotisations supplémentaires pour la
branche retraite quelle mesure le
gouvernement prend-il pour augmenter les
salaires qui finalement sont le fruit de
ce débat également parce que petit
salaire petite retraite nous le savons
tous pourquoi ne bougez-vous pas sur le
SMIC nous poursuivrons le débat jusqu'à
ce que vous apportiez des réponses à ces
questions qui nous semblent essentielles
par CIM monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
trouve qu'on est dans un affrontement
gauche-droite
et oui parce que monsieur le ministre a
raison soit on prend deux années de vie
et les deux plus belles années à la
retraite à des millions de travailleurs
et travailleurs soit on trouve des
nouvelles pistes de financement c'est ça
la réalité et donc nous on vous propose
dans cette série là d'élargir l'assiette
pour les hauts revenus ce supérieur à
3667 euros on aura d'autres pistes de
financement on l'a dit et surtout les
bancs si on fait enfin l'égalité
salariale dans ce pays c'est de suite 6
milliards de cotisations sociales si on
gagne la bataille de l'emploi un million
de travailleurs et travailleuses de plus
en activité c'est de suite 10 milliards
ou si on fait cotiser les revenus du
capital au même titre que ceux du
travail alors là je vous dis pas c'est
26 milliards d'euros donc vous voyez
nous on est sur des nouvelles pistes de
financement on vous offre une palette
décidant et tranche entre nous la
majorité du peuple français va vous le
redire demain avec grande force personne
ne veut travailler deux ans plus parce
que si le travail est source
d'épanouissement et de liens social pour
beaucoup de travailleurs et
travailleuses les utiles essentiels de
ce pays c'est aussi source de souffrance
psychiques et physique et donc non on ne
veut pas voler les deux plus belles
années et donc nous pensons qu'il faut
avoir un vrai débat allez arrêter
l'obstruction silencieuse débattez avec
nous sur quoi vous êtes d'accord vous
voulez pas élargir l'assiette des côtés
des hauts revenus très bien dites nous
il y a 10 milliards à trouver dans une
perspective lointaine dans le vin ou 30
ans donc on a le temps de débattre
cherchons les chiffres ensemble allons-y
je suis sûr que vous avez aussi des
belles propositions on est prêt à vous
entendre et à se mettre d'accord sur un
compromis
75% des gens ne veulent pas et ils
soutiennent la grève reconductible à
partir de demain on devrait quand même
entendre ça tous ensemble je vous
remercie
madame madame meunier
oui merci monsieur le Président il n'y a
pas de hasard et pourquoi est-ce que ce
projet de loi est si impopulaire
pourquoi est-ce que si Français sur 10
sont opposés à cette réforme c'est parce
que ça touche exclusivement les ménages
et les ménages les plus modestes oui il
y a un autre une autre possibilité de
financement des économistes le disent
Michael Zemmour par exemple donne
d'autres pistes et si nous sommes
nombreux ici à défendre les propositions
que nos collègues du groupe CRCE
défendent ici c'est que il est possible
d'avoir un autre financement que de
ponctionner les ménages les plus
modestes et donc devant ce caractère
injuste ses amendements poursuivent le
même objectif rétablir de la justice
sociale sur ce qui n'en est pas
aujourd'hui
merci encore une prise de parole madame
Cu Karman ensuite je donnerai la parole
aux rapporteur Savary madame ku Karman
président messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues il me semble qu'il y
a finalement un débat que nous n'avons
pas peut-être parce que nous n'aurons
pas l'aborder mais qui est finalement
est-ce que oui ou non dans notre pays la
retraite à une utilité sociale
est-ce que oui ou non ce que à la langue
française d'ailleurs à qualifier de 3e
âge puis de quatrième âge est-ce que
c'est temps là de la vie
corresponde un besoin dont chacune et
chacun individuellement doit en
ressentir et en approuvé les
satisfactions et est-ce que
collectivement nous avons besoin de ces
femmes de ces hommes que tout un chacun
et je ne serai l'offense à personne ici
mais que tout à chacun nous rencontrons
au quotidien
vous et nous les connaissons toutes et
tous vous savez
ces milliers d'élus locaux
qui aujourd'hui parce qu'il bénéficie
d'un système de retraite qui leur
permettent de partir à l'âge de la
retraite en bonne santé vous les
connaissez vous les connaissez toutes et
tous ces femmes ces hommes que nous
rencontrons plus régulièrement les
vendredis soirs les samedis après-midi
les dimanches matin ces femmes et ses
hommes qui animent l'ensemble de notre
de nos associations et que même si à la
fin de chaque assemblée générale nous
faisons le constat qu'il faudrait
renouveler nous nous sommes satisfaits
qu'il y a encore ces jeunes retraités
ces retraités dynamiques qui font vivre
ce fameux vivre ensemble que nous
appelons toutes et tous de nos vœux mais
qui les incarne au quotidien vous
connaissez toutes et tous ces femmes et
ces hommes qui devant les sorties
d'écoles sont là pour soulager
accompagner alors oui nous le disons
nous voterons ces différents amendements
Monsieur Merci
je le rapporteur Sabari
oui mais chaque sénateur a le droit de
prendre la parole si je juge pas utile
mes collègues c'est le juge pas utile
mes collègues de prendre la parole c'est
que peut-être quelque part faut se poser
des questions et que l'effet répétitif
d'amendement similaire modifiant
simplement un petit pourcentage un petit
pourcentage
de cotisations
supplémentaires il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n'expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de l'attribut pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
il faut leur dire la vérité aux gens
ils prennent pas deux ans à cause de la
réforme ils prennent selon toujours le
mécanisme que vous connaissez bien des
délais supplémentaires liés
effectivement faut le reconnaître et
nous assumons nos responsabilités un
décalage d'âge que l'on préconise est
lié à l'augmentation de la durée 43 ans
qui a fait l'augmentation de la durée
c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans les gens
ont déjà pris la plupart du temps ils
ont pris le délai supplémentaire
assumez-le parce que c'était facile
excusez-moi c'était facile
merci oui oui
mille excuses mille excuses
mais faut assumer tu le rapporteur
s'exprimer facile de prendre des
réformes qui concernent les suivants et
les réformes touraines elles commencent
seulement à s'appliquer et elle va faire
ses effets-là mais dites-le dans les
manifestations si vous travaillez plus
longtemps c'est à cause de nous quand
même et pas forcément à cause d'eux donc
si vous voulez si vous voulez jouer sur
ce terrain là nous sommes preneurs mais
faut dire l'ensemble des thématiques les
effets positifs et les effets négatifs
alors un volontiers vous voyez à travers
le corps une justification le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites il y a des
gens qui nous écoutent
vous voyez des significations
simplement vous oubliez de dire que tous
les scénarios même les plus optimistes
conduisent à une dégradation des comptes
de retraite avec une retraite plus
faible des retraités baisse du pouvoir
relativement au salaire moyen baisse du
pouvoir des retraités
85% à l'horizon 2030 2040 contre 103%
dites-le à vos amis que vous êtes
favorables à une baisse de leur niveau
de vie aux retraités ce sera sans dire
la vérité
et bien face à cela
face à cela face à cela nous sommes
responsables et nous prenons les
décisions qu'il faut parce que nous ne
voulons pas nous que nos enfants à
travailler jusque 65 ans nous ne voulons
pas nous que nos enfants et à travailler
plus de 43 ans 45 46 ans parce que c'est
ça l'équivalent d'une absence de prise
de responsabilité les suivants vont
hériter une dégradation de notre système
et il se la réforme sera encore plus
brutale plus en tard d'apprendre les
décisions plus la réforme est brutale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes attentifs et je vous invite mes
chers collègues vous qui êtes sensibles
à la prise en compte des mers de famille
d'attendre les articles qui vont
effectivement faire que nous prenons des
mesures tout à fait significatives pour
les maires de famille car nous aussi
nous en parlons pas nous faisons des
propositions
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame Lubin une réaction de Madame
Lubin
alors puisqu'on commence à se parler
puisqu'on commence à se parler
franchement
ah vous étiez impatient alors on va
revenir en arrière on va revenir en
arrière qui sait qui a permis aux
ouvriers de ce pays qui jusqu'en 1981
commençait à travailler à 14 ans qui
finissait à 75 mais ouais c'est pas si
vieux que ça qui finissait à 65 et qui
mourait avant d'avoir tout juste après
avoir profité de quelques mois de
carrière qui c'est qui est revenu en
arrière immédiatement qui sait qu'un 93
à placer le calcul sur les 25 meilleures
années pour faire baisser le niveau des
retraites qui c'est qui en 2010 est
passé de 2003 ou 2010 je sais plus qui
est passé et passé de 60 à 62 ans et
malgré tout et malgré tout il a fallu
faire encore des réformes la preuve que
celle que vous aviez faite elles étaient
mauvaises pour les salariés et mauvaise
pour le système pour le régime de
retraite et pour son équilibre c'est ça
la réalité et la réforme Touraine j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire hier oui elle a
mis à 43 exactement
mais elle a continué à permettre à des
gens qui commençaient à travailler avant
20 ans de partir à 62 et c'est à ça que
vous allez toucher aujourd'hui je vous
ai écouté jusqu'au bout chers collègues
et c'est à ça que vous allez toucher
aujourd'hui alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît moi ce que je sais quand je
regarde 40 ans en arrière 40 ans c'est
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
politique
ce que je sais c'est que s'il n'y avait
jamais eu de gauche au pouvoir les
ouvriers travailleraient toujours
jusqu'à 65 ans voire même pourquoi pour
pourquoi pas un peu plus mais si ça
serait ça la réalité et quand vous nous
dites que vous ne voulez pas que vos
enfants travaillent
vous inquiétez pas vous aurez la suite
au prochain numéro merci
monsieur Lurel
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président notre
rapporteur étant général un homme
pondéré
j'ose dire raisonnable et c'est vrai que
ça tonalité n'est pas agressive mais
quelquefois il y a des perles qui
passent et on peut pas laisser faire je
dirais pour la bonne information de tous
personnellement moi en tant que
socialiste je n'ai pas de regret ni de
honte pour la loi Touraine je rappelle
c'était non non mais on l'assume ça et
d'ailleurs ça devrait être la dernière
réforme si on veut élargir le périmètre
des recettes vous vous cantonnez dans un
système qui est le vôtre à savoir il
faut voir faire payer les autres c'est
uniquement les salariés qui devraient
cotiser pour eux-mêmes moi j'estime dans
une conception qui n'est pas extensible
de la répartition que l'autre doit se
payer que le capital les dividendes à
payer que oui la CSG on peut voir un
partage euh tout ça devrait se faire je
rappelle que c'était l'augmentation des
pensions agricoles pour atteindre au
moins 75 % nos amis communistes ont
élargi à 85%. et je rappelle que depuis
2003 loi Fillon on aurait dû avoir déjà
les 1200 € les 85 % de Smic net on
attend toujours comme la sœur Anne du
compte de Perrot c'était également
l'amélioration de la retraite
complémentaire des conjoints
collaborateurs et je passe c'était la
création du compte personnel de
pénibilité c'était la comptabilisation
des périodes de maternité des trimestres
j'ai encore deux minutes oui j'ai encore
c'était la réforme c'est vrai c'est vrai
tous les trois ans de 2020 à 2035 de la
durée de cotisations pour une cible de
162 vous accélérer tout ça c'était la
revalorisation de la SPA bref je peux
être très long sur ça vous ne retenez
que ça parce que vous l'enfermez dans un
système qui serait dégrade c'est de la
physique c'est de l'entropie et vous
voulez nous enfermer et nous
inoculer un complexe d'infériorité sur
ça je réclame ça à toute merci Monsieur
et de manière Lucie des conséquente
merci monsieur Lurel la parole est à
Monsieur Boyer
monsieur Boyer
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement hier je vous ai posé une
petite devinette j'ai l'impression que
il y en a qui n'était pas là donc je
vais la reposer aujourd'hui
si si c'est quand même intéressant parce
que vous parlez de la réforme Touraine
khadi madame Touraine il y a 10 ans
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit exactement
il faut l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation
allongement de la durée de cotisation
sa réforme le système de retraite va
droit dans le mur elle l'a dit il y a 10
ans
vous entendez bien ce que je dis là
il faut demander aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps il faut
demander aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps il y en a ici qui l'ont voté
alors pourquoi à cette époque pourquoi
c'était beau à cette époque vous n'avez
pas sorti tous ces arguments que vous
nous sortez aujourd'hui c'est assez
incompréhensible donc je vois qu'il y en
a certaines qui sont gênés c'est vrai
que vous êtes gêné c'est normal que vous
soyez gêné mais je crois que il faut
vous rendre à une évidence il faut vous
rendre une évidence aujourd'hui qu'il y
a la nécessité d'avancer de trouver des
solutions lorsque l'on aura plus de
retraités que d'actifs ça c'est une
réalité que vous redis régulièrement le
rapporteur n'est pas le Savary il a
beaucoup de mérite de vouloir dire très
souvent mais je voulais encore vous leur
dire une seule fois ça me paraît
important entendez bien entendez bien ce
qu'elle a dit allongement de la durée de
cotisation sans réforme de système de
retraite va droit dans le mur et il faut
demander aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps vous l'avez bien entendu
bien merci je vous propose il y a encore
deux demandes d'intervention on va les
donner ensuite on va passer au vote sur
cette série d'amendements ou madame
Ferret
on va rejoindre Alex poussa à rentrer
une de presse Alexandre a entendu de
vivre des échanges dans l'hémicycle
effectivement Quentin ça commençait à
s'agiter ici dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
alors on le rappelle depuis bientôt près
d'une heure et demie les sénateurs
débattes de hausse de cotisation
retraite sur les employeurs et sur les
hauts salaires pour financer ce régime
des retraites et jusqu'à présent il y
avait toute une série de prise de parole
communistes et également de sénateurs
d'autres groupes politiques de gauche
sur ces hausses de cotisation et en face
les sénateurs les républicains étaient
complètement silencieux car ils ne
veulent pas perdre de temps dans les
débats le sénateur communiste Fabien gay
a un peu tensé ségolet ses collègues de
la droite en leur demandant d'arrêter je
cite leur obstruction silencieuse de
venir débat de cette question du
financement de nos retraites faut-il
augmenter les cotisations faut-il
augmenter le temps de travail pour
financer ce régime et là à ce moment là
un sénateur de la républicain s’est levé
pour prendre la parole il s'agit de René
Paul à Savary le rapporteur de la
branche vieillesse ici au Sénat et il a
dénoncé les amendements déposés en série
par les sénateurs communistes pour
allonger les débats perdre du temps
faire des effets de tribune comme a dit
René Paul Savary et puis après ils sont
mépris assez collègues socialiste en
leur appelant la réforme des retraites
de Marisol Touraine qui a été fait sous
le quinquennat de François Hollande une
réforme qui a allongé progressivement la
durée de cotisation pour atteindre 43
annuités en 2035 et René Paul Savary a
dit à ses collègues de gauche et bien
demain dans toutes les manifestations en
France qu'il fallait rappeler aux
manifestants que c'était à cause de la
gauche que les travailleurs allaient
travailler plus longtemps dans les
prochaines années à cause de cette
réforme Touraine et donc ça c'est un
petit peu réveillé les sénateurs
socialistes et la signatrice socialiste
Monique Lubin a été obligé de répondre à
son collègue Savary sous la bronca de
droite les applaudissements de gauche
voilà on a vraiment senti l'ambiance
montée dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et
Monique Lubin a rappelé quand même la
réforme de la retraite à 60 ans faite en
1980 au début du premier mandat de
François Mitterrand voilà pour elle ça
c'est un acquis de la gauche socialiste
à la rappeler également que la réforme
Touraine souffrance Hollande et bien
avait mis en place un dispositif
carrière longue qui faisait que ceux qui
avaient commencé à travailler avant 20
ans pouvait partir à 62 ans et que ce
dispositif il allait être détricoté ou
en tout cas aggraver par la réforme des
manuels Macron voilà le ton est un petit
peu monté dans cette émission et on va
maintenant passer au vote sur ces
propositions de hausse de cotisation qui
sont faites par les sénateurs
communistes tout à fait Alex mais avant
ça il reste une dernière explication de
vote et c'est la vice-présidente
socialiste Laurence Rossignol qui
s'exprime à l'écoute le retour
des 35 heures tout le mal qui pense des
statut social des Français tout le mal
qui pense de ce pays avec ses acquis
sociaux des congés payés des Français
qui sont des fainéants les gages c'est
ça votre politique et c'est les Français
qui vont payer vos gains si cette
réforme aboutissait et nous ferons tout
pour qu'elle n'aboutissent pas
bon alors écoutez je vous propose irai
dire encore deux qui lèvent la main à
droite à gauche ou alors donner la
parole et ensuite on va passer au vote
donc monsieur Hainaut et Madame Poncet
non oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres au fond c'est un
débat extrêmement intéressant disons-le
assez clivé totalement clivé mais il est
extrêmement clivé sur la valeur travail
voyez c'est ça qui fait la différence
entre nous c'est que j'entends on a volé
deux ans aux Français mais enfin
franchement c'est pas parce qu'on
travaille deux ans de plus qu'on vole
deux ans de vie tout de même ça n'a rien
à voir et combien ici et même et même
chez vous combien ici se réalise par le
travail et s'épanouissent par le travail
en toute objectivité vous parlez encore
comme si on était au 18e siècle et Émile
Verhaeren que les sirènes se taisent
mais c'est pas ça aujourd'hui le travail
le travail c'est l'épanouissement alors
qu'on dise que de la qualité au travail
qu'on discute de la rémunération qu'on
discute de la formation tout au long de
la vie oui mais je vous citerai il faut
toujours un peu de poésie Jules Renard
qui disait le travail pense la
paraisseront
la vie fleurie par le travail je vous
remercie mes chers collègues
madame poncemos madame Poncet
oui merci monsieur le Président moi
je voudrais René Paul Savary qui essaie
de nous démontrer c'est régulièrement
que de toute façon seul compte les faits
Touraine j'ai bien compris donc je me
demande du coup pourquoi vous déplacez
l'âge et si seul compte les 43 ans je
vous propose déjà de mettre l'âge de
départ à 60 ans c'est une revendication
des écologistes voilà parce que pourquoi
et pourquoi faites-vous cette erreur je
m'explique à ces vide vous dites l'âge
moyen du fait de l'effet Touraine fait
qu'on part à 63 ans etc donc nous on
change rien 64 ans on ajoute quelques
mois mais c'est l'âge moyen monsieur le
rapporteur il y en a qui partent à 62 il
y en a qui partent à 62 et demi d'autres
à 63 ans il y a un cadre sur deux qui
part à 63 ans ce cadre sur deux vous
allez l'obliger à rester et tous ces
gens qui partaient avant 64 ans et qui
sont quand même importants ils vont
devoir aller à 64 donc
uniquement l'âge moyen va se déplacer
alors dans plus ou moins progressivement
enfin sur cinq ans mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que l'âge moyen ne justifie
pas que vous portiez là je les gale à
l'âge moyen parce que c'est moyen enfin
le bon sens quelquefois c'est la terre
est plate elle est ronde et là l'âge
moyen donc les faits de l'âge là devient
plus important que les faits Touraine
laissez les gens arbitrer et
éventuellement partir avec des cotes
c'est ce que vous empêchez en mettant
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans c'est pour ça
que la CGC dit que c'est une loi
liberticide je pense qu'elle pense à ces
quatre sur deux qui vont devoir contre
leur grille rester encore un an au
travail dans des organisations de
travail souvent toxiques
bien merci alors il y a des mains qui se
lèvent mais je propose qu'on passe au
vote c'est un débat passionnant que nous
allons poursuivre que nous allons
poursuivre à l'occasion je pense
d'autres amendements donc sur cette
série d'amendements je vais les
soumettre un parent
au vote d'autant qu'il y a sur certains
d'entre eux sur deux d'entre eux des
demandes de scrutin public donc quand on
en sera là je vous le dirai donc nous
commençons par l'amendement 2975
[Musique]
présenté par le groupe socialiste qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 2630 qui a été présenté
également par des sénateurs socialistes
qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté donc sur
l'amendement
284 j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste la vie de
la commission est défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par la petite 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà vous vivez ce scrutin public en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat on
l'a compris les communistes notamment
qui ont déposé des dizaines
d'amendements pour proposer des méthodes
alternatives de financement de notre
régime de retraite par répartition c'est
dérouler ensuite un débat assez vite
dans les mystique là puisque on n'est
pas le Savary a bien dit de redire de la
part de la gauche que c'était tel
qu'elle avait voté l'accélération
effectivement de la réforme Touraine et
donc on voit comme cela la gauche qui
maintenant et bien se justifie de cette
réforme Touraine dans l'hémicycle on a
entendu notamment elle est sénateurs
socialistes revendiquer la paternité de
cette réforme mais en la nu ensemble il
y avait des critères de pénibilité à
l'époque a bien redit on bien redit
c'est sénateurs de gauche c'est la fin
de ce scrutin public on va écouter le
résultat
votons 343 exprimé 335 pour 91 contre
244 le Sénat n'a pas adopté je passe à
l'amendement
4283 présenté par le groupe communiste
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le 4282
présenté par le groupe communiste même
vote
le
4281 même vote
un bot le 4280 même vote
le 4279 même vote
le 4278
le 4277 même vote
le 4276 même vote
le 4275 même botte
le 4274 même vote le 4273 vote
4272 même vote
4271 même vote
4270 même vote
4269 même vote
4346 j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE la vie
de la commission est défavorable à vie
du gouvernement défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà nous sommes toujours sur la même
dizaine d'amendements de voilà
d'amendements qui viennent poser
d'autres solutions de financement
proposées par la gauche de l'hémicycle
et on voit ses votes à chaque fois qu'il
y a des scrute un public avec des
mesures comme celle-ci et bien il y a
ces 91 voient pour et c'est 240 voix
contre un qui sont donc et bien les
ratios entre la gauche et la droite
sénatoriale et qui sont des ratios qui
ressortent à chaque fois sur ces
scrutins publics retour dans l'hémicycle
pour écouter le résultat de ce scrutin
primé 336 pour 91 contre 245 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté enfin le
4344 présenté par le groupe communiste
qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté et le
4345 par le groupe communiste même Bott
même vote nous avons donc fini avec
cette série d'amendements en discussion
commune et nous continuons avec le
2882 nous attaquons une discussion avec
deux amendements de discussion commune
de 1882 présenté par Monsieur gilet je
remercie monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est amendement de notre
groupe visa moduler à la hausse les
cotisations patronales d'assurance
vieillesse en fonction des politiques
salariales d'emploi et de formation des
entreprises ainsi que du respect
d'objectif écologique et
environnementaux en fait il s'agit de
mettre en perspective l'action de
l'entreprise dans sa responsabilité
sociétale donc le taux de cotisation
d'assurance vieillesse la charge de
l'employeur pourrait être majorée en
fonction du nombre de fin de contrat de
travail à l'exclusion des démissions la
nature du contrat de travail et sa durée
la politique salariale de l'entreprise
notamment de l'objectif d'égalité
professionnelle politique de formation
de l'entreprise du respect par
l'entreprise d'engagement écologique et
environnementaux dans cas de la
responsabilité sociale de la taille de
l'entreprise dans les entreprises d'au
moins 50 salariés le comité social et
économique serait donc consultés sur
l'application du présent article au
titre de ces attributions consultatives
mentionnées à l'article suffisait du
Code du travail son avis serait transmis
à une commission spécifique de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse les
modalités de calcul de la majoration de
cotisations patronales et de contrôle
des représentants du personnel serait
donc déterminés par décret en Conseil
d'État l'intérêt donc de cet amendement
et bien de placer l'entreprise dans sa
responsabilité sociétale et donc
d'introduire une question de bonus malus
au niveau des entreprises comme les
salariés et les retraités peuvent avoir
un bonus et un malus et c'était quitté
en termes de présentation serait
particulièrement intéressante ça serait
donc une forme d'agilité aujourd'hui
dans l'accompagnement des dispositifs de
retraite pour tracer une trajectoire qui
serait donc vertueuse et accompagnée au
mieux les parcours professionnels des
salariés merci le 3141 madame ronce
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement
si vous nous rejoignez bienvenue nous
sommes au cinquième jour de la réforme
des retraites au Sénat on va faire un
petit point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire qui se trouve en tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle Alexandre on
vient d'insister à 1h30 de débats et
quelques échanges assez vif on peut le
dire effectivement Quentin on peut dire
que ça a été un débat en début
d'après-midi qui s'est déroulé sur un
rythme diesel ça a mis du temps à
démarrer avec une petite vingtaine
d'amendements des sénateurs communistes
pour augmenter certaines cotisations
retraite les cotisations retraite des
employeurs et également les cotisations
retraite des plus hauts salaires au-delà
de 3700 euros mensuels écoutez la
réponse du ministre des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal sur ses propositions c'est
un nom catégorique vous avez aujourd'hui
10% des Français qui payent 70% de
l'impôt sur le revenu
vous avez des Français qui travaillent
qui travaillent dur qui peuvent être
dans ce niveau de salaire qui voit
beaucoup d'argent public qui est investi
dépensé pour accompagner des Français
qui ne travaillent pas moi j'arrête
aussi sur les classe moyennes françaises
qui aujourd'hui ont le sentiment qu'on
leur demande toujours à elle les efforts
pour financer des mesures qui ne les
concernent jamais voilà hors de question
pour le gouvernement d'augmenter les
impôts pour les Français alors dans ce
débat on a entendu beaucoup de prises de
parole de la gauche notamment de
sénateurs communistes mais aucune
intervention des sénateurs les
républicains dans la première heure
alors le sénateur communiste Fabien gay
a essayé de les remuer un peu et de leur
demander de s'exprimer nous on est sur
des nouvelles pistes de financement on
vous offre une palette décidons les
tranches entre nous la majorité du
peuple français va vous le redire demain
avec grande force personne ne veut
travailler deux ans plus parce que si le
travail est source d'épanouissement et
le lien social pour beaucoup de
travailleurs et travailleuses les utiles
essentiels de ce pays c'est aussi une
source de souffrance psychique et
physique et donc non on ne veut pas
voler les deux plus belles années et
donc nous pensons qu'il faut avoir un
vrai débat allez arrêter l'obstruction
silencieuse débattez avec nous
voilà l'obstruction silencieuse de la
droite qui est dénoncé par la gauche
alors que les sénateurs de la
républicains eux dénoncent à
l'obstruction cordiale qui est faite par
la gauche sénatoriale alors dans ce
débat et bien au final un sénateur les
républicains s'est levé pour répondre à
la gauche il s'agit de René Paul Savary
le rapporteur de la branche vieillesse
de la sécurité sociale ici au Sénat
écoutez à ce que René Paul Savary a dit
à la gauche
et que l'effet répétitif d'amendement
similaire modifiant simplement un petit
pourcentage un petit pourcentage
de cotisations
supplémentaires et il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n'expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de la tribune pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
voilà la droite sanatoriale qui s'agace
vraiment cet après-midi du temps perdu
et de tous ses amendements qui sont
discutés tranquillement par leurs
collègues de gauche alors pour faire un
petit peu de provocation et bien René
Paul Savary a rappelé à ses collègues
socialistes que et bien sous le
gouvernement de sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande il y a eu la réforme
des retraites de Marisol Touraine qui a
allongé la durée de cotisation à 43 ans
progressivement 43 ans qui seront
atteints en 2035 il a dit à ses
collègues socialistes et bien demain
dans les manifestations expliquées aux
manifestants que c'est aussi à cause de
la gauche que les Français vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps dans les
prochaines années alors forcément ça
peut faire un petit peu piquer les
sénateurs socialistes écoutez la réponse
qui a été faite par l'une d'entre eux
Monique le bain
quand je regarde 40 ans en arrière 40
ans c'est quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à la politique
ce que je sais c'est que s'il n'y avait
jamais eu de gauche au pouvoir les
ouvriers travailleraient toujours
jusqu'à 65 ans voire même pourquoi pour
pourquoi pas un peu plus ah mais si ça
serait ça
la réalité voilà les socialistes qui ont
besoin de défendre leur bilan historique
sur les précédentes réformes des
retraites et puis notez que cet
après-midi et bien de nouveaux
amendements sur des hausses de
cotisation retraite vont être débattues
durant toute cette après-midi merci
alexandre Poussin pour ces explications
très complètes au micro de Public Sénat
et pour information puisque vous le
mentionnez on a appris qu'une délégation
des trois groupes de gauche se rendra
bien à la manif de demain à Paris départ
du Sénat à 13h effectivement les
Français regardent ces débats sans doute
regarde
ces débats sur Public Sénat retour au
débats en direct dans l'hémicycle
ce qu'il faut arrêter c'est le flux des
licenciements des seniors parce qu'ils
coûtent trop cher ou parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas suivre le rythme de travail
de l'intensité du travail dans les
entreprises
merci donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable sur ces deux amendements je
vais les soumettre aux voix le premier
le 2882 qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
deuxième le 3141 qui est pour
qui contre s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je passe ensuite à l'amendement
4347 présentée par Madame Marayas merci
monsieur le Président par cet amendement
nous proposons de majorer les
cotisations vieillesse des entreprises
qui n'ont pas conclu de plantes
d'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes les inégalités
salariales tout le monde le sait
persiste selon l'Observatoire des
inégalités les femmes perçoivent un
salaire
28,5% inférieur à celui des hommes une
part ce phénomène s'explique par la
précarité des femmes à l'emploi avec
niveau de temps partiel subit
rappelons-le bien sûr culminant à 28,1%
contre
7,6% pour les hommes mais emploi et
attend de travail strictement équivalent
l'écart est toujours de 5,3% c'est la
proportion discrimination la plus basse
des femmes au travail pourtant le
principe d'égalité salariale est un
principe qui a été maintes fois énoncé à
l'article 23 de la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme du 10
décembre 8
promu par l'Organisation internationale
du travail dans une convention ratifiée
par la France en 1952 inscrit à
l'article 119 du traité de Rome du 25
mars 1957 le principe a travaillé égal
salaire égal introduit dans notre corpus
législatif également par la loi du 22
décembre 1972 nous devrions donc
attendre encore monsieur le ministre
Olivier dussotte vous annoncier à
l'occasion de l'article 2 sur l'index
des seniors des résultats positifs qui
seraient présentés la semaine prochaine
en matière d'égalité professionnelle il
serait suiteable que vous puissiez nous
apporter des précisions car ce ne sont
pas tout à fait les données dont nous
disposons le principe à travailler égal
salaire égal est une revendication
primaire fondamentale qui générerait pas
moins des 11 milliards d'euros de
cotisations supplémentaires
5,5 milliards d'euros net à terme
nous savons tous que les salaires sont
des cotisations et nous ne devons jamais
l'oublier votons cette amendement de
justice pour les femmes et pour
accroître les recettes de notre régime
par répartition merci Madame barrière si
nous saluons effectivement monsieur
Duchamps qui nous a rejoint pour cet
après-midi
avis de la commission sur cette
amendement je vous préviens je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
sur cet amendement donc préparez-vous
allez-y madame la rapporteur défavorable
défavorable monsieur le ministre
défavorable donc double avis défavorable
donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement
je vous rappelle que la Commission donc
et le gouvernement donné un double avis
défavorable donc il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'artiste 56 du règlement
scrutin est ouvert voilà la sonnerie
retentit dans l'hémicycle et dans les
couloirs du Sénat il y a un nouveau
scrutin public assez scrutin qui sont
utilisés par la gauche pour ralentir un
peu le débat puisque au lieu de voter à
main levée les sénateurs votent via des
cartes électroniques ou alors leur
président de groupe va te via une
délégation de vote pour l'ensemble du
groupe politique s'il y est autorisé par
assez collègues c'est ce qui permet
d'avoir la cartographie complète de
l'hémicycle qui s'affiche sur les écrans
dans l'hémicycle lorsqu'on a le résultat
du scrutin plus personne ne demande à
voter donc et bien Pierre Laurent a
pardonné le résultat de ce scrutin donc
quelques secondes on l'écoute
donc le scrutin
bouton 343 exprimé 342 pour 91 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
amendement
4349 madame la Présidente assassin merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais me
permettre quelques petits rappels Sanofi
c'est près de 1700 suppressions de poste
en 2020 et une distribution de
dividendes de plus de 4 milliards
d'euros BNP Paribas première banque
française entend supprimer 921 poste en
France alors même que la maison mère a
affiché en 2022 à bénéfice net record de
plus de 10 milliards d'euros novastis
près de 400 emplois risque d'être
supprimés en France alors que
l'entreprise affiche en 2021 52
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires Microsoft près de 206
salariés sur la sellette soit 10% de ces
effectifs cela alors même que la filiale
française connaît une forte croissance
alors ces exemples viennent s'ajouter
quand même à une liste toujours plus
importante d'entreprises qui ont
bénéficié bénéficier et bénéficier
encore largement des 200 êtres publiques
recensés d'exonération en tout genre et
de la baisse massive de la fiscalité du
capital je citerai Renault Airbus Valeo
Vallourec et cette liste est loin d'être
exhaustive or le chômage c'est un
véritable fléau pour la société bien
évidemment comme pour les habitudes
individus la mortalité des chômeurs et
trois fois supérieure à celle des
personnes en emploi et on estime le
nombre de morts par an à plus de 14000
notamment à cause des suicides et nous
vous l'avons dit répéter cette réforme
est une machine à fabriquer de la
précarité et du chômage en particulier
pour les femmes et les personnes en fin
de carrière
la mise en concurrence des seniors avec
d'autres actifs des gradera l'accès à un
emploi pour de catégories donc les
jeunes les femmes les personnes au
chômage ainsi que les Conditions
Générales de travail des actifs c'est
pourquoi notre amendement vise à faire
davantage contribuer les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés qui pratiquent des
licenciements économiques à notre sens
injustifié qui n'ont pour que qui n'ont
pour ça l'objectif que d'améliorer les
bénéfices pour se conformer aux
exigences du marché je vous remercie
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement et favorable défavorable
monsieur le ministre défavorable donc un
double avis défavorable monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues de
l'amendement présenté par la présidente
assassy et un très bon amendement et un
amendement important parce que la
question qui nous est posée n'est pas de
savoir s'il faut prendre les deux plus
belles années
de l'âge à la retraite à des millions et
des millions de travailleurs et
travailleurs la seule question qui
devrait nous animer
cet après-midi et les prochaines
semaines c'est de gagner la bataille de
l'emploi on nous dit et on ne cesse de
nous répéter que le pays est en train de
se réindustrialiser après la crise du
covid et partout on s'aperçoit que c'est
faux là elle vient de donner un certain
nombre de chiffres et d'éléments sur la
aérien Air France étant de sous-traitant
et sous-traitant mais aussi beaucoup
d'usines prenons les fonderies
bientôt il n'y aura plus une seule
fonderie en France c'est ça la réalité
du quotidien et donc aujourd'hui les
pièces détachées notamment de nos
véhicules Renault seront fabriqués
demain en Espagne ou en Allemagne ou de
l'autre côté de la planète voici la
réalité et donc
et donc la bataille qui devrait nous
animer ici c'est celle de gagner la
bataille pour l'emploi parce que nous
cessons de vous le dire un million de
travailleurs et de travailleuses de plus
en activité c'est moi d'abord de
d'allocations chômage mais c'est surtout
des milliards de cotisations nettes de
suite et donc si la perspective dans le
même temps c'est 10 milliards déficits
ben nous n'en n'avons plus si nous
remettons un million de travailleurs et
de travailleurs en activité et donc je
trouve dommage que sur un amendement que
nous venons proposer il n'est pas un
débat qui s'engage sur comment
réellement réindustrialiser le pays et
non pas des déclarations d'intention qui
sont en réalité que la communication
politique
bien merci donc double avis défavorable
sur cet amendement je vais le soumettre
aux voix un moment 4349 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite l'amendement
2881 madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vise à
augmenter d'un point le taux de
cotisation d'assurance vieillesse comme
le préconise le comité
consultation
des retraites d'orientation des
retraites le montant total des
cotisations versées au régime des
retraites s'élevaient en 2021 à 227
milliards d'euros d'après le Haut
Commissariat aux plantes une hausse de
l'ordre de 1 point des cotisations
patronales retraite les augmenteraient
de quelques 7 milliards 500 millions
soit environ 15% du besoin de
financement annuel moyen calculer d'ici
2047 une telle hausse requerrait de
faire passer le taux des cotisations
retraite employeur à 17,5 % du salaire
brut contre 16,5% actuellement cette
recette
supplémentaire entre autres pistes
permettrait donc d'améliorer
significativement le financement de la
branche retraite
merci avis de la commission voilà retour
en salle des conférences ici la salle
qui jouxte l'hémicycle se déroule le ce
débat je suis avec Laurence Rossignol
bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente socialiste du Sénat
ancienne ministre des familles et les
droits des femmes un mot sur ce qui se
joue dans l'hémicycle depuis 14h30 on
voit cette série d'amendements qui
présente une alternative dans le
financement au régime des retraites et
votre rapporteur général votre
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse qui
vous accuse d'utiliser ces amendements
pour avoir une tribune dans l'émission
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez écoutez
le Parlement est une tribune pour tout
le monde y compris pour la droite et la
majorité bien sûr que nous avons des
choses à partager avec les Français
tout le raisonnement qui fonde le report
de 62 64 ans de l'âge de la retraite et
fondé sur l'idée qu'il y aurait un
déséquilibre démographique mais il y a
plusieurs façons d'envisager ces
questions de déséquilibre on peut
comparer le nombre d'actifs le nombre
d'inactifs on peut comparer le nombre de
cotisants le nombre de pensionnés chose
peut aussi comparer la richesse produite
et le nombre de pensionnés les gains de
productivité qui ont marqué les
dernières décennies ils ont compensé le
fait qu'on ait moins nombreux à cotiser
ils peuvent ils peuvent tout à fait
compenser le fait qu'il y a moins
d'actifs qu'il y a d'inactif aujourd'hui
je donne un autre exemple si les femmes
étaient payées comme les hommes il n'y
aurait plus aucun sujet sur les
ressources de l'assurance vieillesse que
dire aussi de ce qu'elle a dit René Paul
Savary dans l'hémicycle lorsque et bien
il dit que vous faites de l'obstruction
finalement au fait qu'on avance plus
vite que cela dans ce texte écoutez
c'est un texte très important j'ai envie
de dire que avec plus d'un million de
personnes déjà dans la rue plusieurs
fois depuis un mois
notre temps de parole doit être
proportionnelle au mouvement que nous
représentons et par ailleurs nous ne
faisons pas d'obstruction tous les
sujets que nous abordons sont des sujets
qui tiennent et qui sont liés
directement implique la réforme des
retraites qu'on est en train de discuter
nous ne lisons pas les pages du
dictionnaire au micro nous travaillons
sur une réforme nous faisons valoir nos
alternatives nos alternatives nous
faisons valoir nos critiques et nos
propositions ce matin c'est peut-être
l'information de la matinée c'est le
vote par le Sénat de cette mesure
proposée par la droite et le centre d'un
CDI senior la gauche a voté contre
pourtant avec un mauvais taux d'emploi
des seniors autour de 56% pour les 54 64
ans on se dit ça pourrait être une bonne
outil pour peut-être favoriser l'emploi
de ces seniors alors nous l'avait appelé
le CDI dernier embauche par référence au
CPE contrat premier embauche
jamais rentré effectivement
en fait nous nous méfions terriblement
de ces exonérations de cotisations ce
sont des milliards et des milliards
d'euros qui sont impactés qui impactent
le budget de l'État le budget de la
protection sociale et contribue
d'ailleurs à ce qu'ensuite on vient de
dire il y a plus assez d'argent qui
rentre donc ce contrat dernière embauche
ce contrat senior que propose le
rapporteur il est encore fondé sur des
nouvelles exonérations de cotisations et
par ailleurs si le gouvernement et le
Parlement doivent discuter de mesure
nouvelle pour l'emploi il faut le faire
avant la discussion sur la réforme des
retraites puisqu'il faut avoir en tête
l'impact correspond-mesure sur l'emploi
pour pouvoir ensuite envisager quelle
est l'application des perspectives sur
les retraites et là le gouvernement
parle d'une loi travail au printemps
donc vous vous dites on a des choses à
l'envers ils ont fait des choses à
l'envers ils vivent mieux valu mettre la
loi travail en hiver et peut-être qu'on
serait rendu compte qu'il y avait plus
besoin après la loi travail de réformer
l'âge de la retraite il nous reste une
minute pour discuter encore d'un sujet
c'est la mobilisation de demain on a
pris que vous alliez vous rendre vous
les sénateurs de gauche via une
délégation dans les cortèges c'est quoi
c'est il est de soutenir de dire que il
y a les échanges entre ce qui se passe
ici au Sénat et de ce qui se passe dans
la rue demain d'abord pour beaucoup
d'entre nous nous avons déjà fait toutes
les manifestations moi je les ai faites
dans mon département tantôt à Compiègne
tantôt à Beauvais les autres les ont
fait pareil dans leur ville et certains
d'entre nous se sont toujours rendus à
la manifestation à Paris donc il y a
rien de nouveau demain de ce point de
vue là nous nous y rendrons comme nous
nous sommes rendus bien entendu nous
sommes les relais les portes-parents du
mouvement social c'est nous qui
traduisons en termes parlementaire dans
la confrontation avec le gouvernement
vous savez les syndicats je crois que
j'ai entendu dire que l'Inter syndical
j'entendu Laurent Berger ce matin que
l'intersey syndicale n'avait pas été
reçu en tant que tel par le gouvernement
nous nous avons la chance de pouvoir
interpeller le ministre ici au Sénat est
porté au ministre ce que nous disent les
représentants syndicaux et les citoyens
qui manifestent tous les regards vont se
tourner vers l'examen de l'article 7
celui sur la mesure d'âge est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut aller vers un
examen de cette mesure après les
manifestations par exemple quelqu'un qui
serait les manifesté qui rentreraient
chez lui allume République Sénat et qui
pourrait avoir ce débat là c'est ce qui
va se passer demain côté le rythme
d'examen dans au Sénat enfin au
Parlement et quelque chose d'assez
aléatoire et pas toujours prévisible ce
que je peux dire c'est que l'article 7
sera examiné au Sénat nous débattrons de
l'article 7 et il sera soumis au vote
c'est une demande désorganisation
syndicales à laquelle nous répondrons
positivement j'ai une dernière question
si vous voulez bien Laurence Rossignol
mais il y a eu ces débats autour et bien
de la réforme Touraine vous étiez membre
du même gouvernement que Marisol
Touraine on entend que effectivement la
droite vous renvoie cet argument sur les
43 annuités qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aux Français qui disent effectivement ce
sont les socialistes qui ont mis cette
barre à carreaux trois ans c'est vrai
d'abord les les rapports du corps
puisque maintenant tous les Français
connaissent leur apport du corps les
rapports
en 2014
le rapport du corps donnait des des
prospectives et des prévisions de dés
libre des finances de la retraite qui
était bien différente de celle de
rapport du corps d'aujourd'hui ça c'est
la première chose et puis dans la
réforme Touraine il y avait aussi le
dispositif carrière longue et les
critères de pénibilité que le
gouvernement Macron s'est dépêcher de
d'amputer dès 2017 quand il est arrivé
au gouvernement et bien merci merci pour
toutes ces explications merci au micro
de Public Sénat nous on va rejoindre
notre journaliste parlementaire
alexandre Poussin dans l'hémicycle
Alexandre dites-nous où est-ce qu'on en
est et bien les sénateurs des Bata
actuellement d'un amendement de la
sénatrice socialiste Monique Lubin pour
augmenter d'un pour cent les cotisations
retraite patronales les cotisations des
employés des employeurs ça représentait
et bien un gain de 7,5 milliards d'euros
pour notre régime de retraite c'est à
dire 15% de ses besoins pour les
prochaines années donc je vous laisse
écouter les débats
ce je ne comprends pas dans ce débat
d'abord premièrement d'autres l'ont dit
avant moi c'est qu'on a l'impression que
le travail est devenu une valeur dans
notre pays qui n'a plus aucune valeur et
que par définition et que par définition
il faudrait qu'il soit le plus court
possible le moins pénible possible et
qu'il ne servent le moins possible alors
que je pense qu'au contraire on en dans
un pays où l'émancipation et par le
travail le deuxième élément c'est que ce
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
qu'on en réfléchisse que par un seul
prisme nous avons il y a pas si
longtemps dans cet essai dans cette
hémicycle il y a peu de semaine eu à
traiter le problème du chômage nous
avions proposé qu’après un CDD ou après
une période d'intérim une personne à qui
il lui est proposé un CDI que ça soit
après un CDD ou après une période
d'intérim puisse soit avoir le choix de
le refuser ce qui est son droit
et de continuer de travailler mais ne
plus avoir la possibilité de percevoir
le chômage les mêmes qui nous expliquent
qu'il faut trouver des financements les
mêmes étaient contre cette ce principe
et pourtant le chômage c'est quoi c'est
le principe de la solidarité pour aider
ce qui perdent leur travail non pas pour
classer la possibilité à celui qui n'a
plus envie de travailler de percevoir le
chômage donc on nous vous ne l'avez pas
voté
et le gouvernement et le gouvernement et
le gouvernement a fini a fini par prier
en acceptant en CMP mais en édulcorant
ce que nous écrivions ce que nous
écrivions c'était de dire un CDD ou une
période d'intérim ne peut pas refuser ne
peut pas percevoir le chômage quand il
refuse un CDI le gouvernement a voulu
qu'il y ait deux périodes de refus ce
qui est inadmissible à partir d'une
croix
de recevoir le chômage et si on faisait
ça et ben je vous garantis qu'on
trouvait des milliards
monsieur vallée
merci monsieur le Président je pense
qu'on entame un débat qui peut être
intéressant et relever un peu le niveau
d'abord on rassure notre collègue
[Musique]
du plan sur le fait qu'il s'est retenu
pendant deux jours on le dira pas à
Bruno retaillod ça restera entre nous le
fait qu'il est brisé la loi du silence
je voudrais dire également
que j'imagine sur ces banques il y a
quand même des gens pour considérer y
compris à gauche que le travail peut
être quelque chose de sain
peut-être quelque chose de fécond
peut-être même quelque chose de généreux
et puisque nous en sommes à dire à
plusieurs reprises qui si on s'occupe du
Sénat et pas de l'Assemblée nationale le
travail sain fécond et généreux qui rend
le peuple libre et l'homme heureux et
c'est une vision à laquelle vous
souscrivez probablement était celle de
notre émérite près de ses sœurs dans ses
rangs de Victor Hugo sur ses sièges
et bien sans démagogie aucune il viendra
l'expliquer aux aides à domicile et je
vous le dis avec émotion que nous avons
tous eu à gérer dans nos collectivités
et qui sont confrontés à de la
pénibilité qui n'est pas prise en compte
et qui est d'autant moins prise en
compte que ces métiers là ont du mal à
se syndiquer ces métiers là ont du mal à
être représentés et à faire entendre
leur voix alors certes on n'est plus au
19e siècle forte heureusement parce
qu'autrement se débala nous ne pourrions
pas la voir de manière aussi
démocratique mais on ne peut pas nier
qu'il y a aujourd'hui du travail qui à
côté de celui que tout le monde souhaite
et dans lequel il veut être épanoui le
travail sain fait qu'en généreux qui
rend le peuple libre et l'homme heureux
il y a encore des modalités de travail
pour lesquelles il faut prendre en
compte la pénibilité et des gens qui
n'ont pas envie de bosser qui n'ont pas
envie de prendre un boulot qui n'ont pas
envie de participer il en existe
peut-être mais il y en a aussi une
partie et ça s'appelle les rentiers
monsieur Tissot
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
simplement
j'ai pas l'impression d'être un sénateur
particulier mais j'ai pas non plus
l'impression d'être hors du temps et
pour reprendre ce que nos collègues tout
à l'heure je veux bien être le site de
le sénateur représentant les plus
grandes feignasses que la terre est
portée ou que la terre porte que notre
pays porte aujourd'hui il s'agit pas de
savoir si on veut continuer travailler
mais c'est de savoir si on peut
continuer de travailler après 62 ans et
ne me dites pas de bêtises ne me dites
pas de bêtises quand vous avez commencé
travailler tôt ou même pas
obligatoiremento mais pendant 20 ans 30
ans 35 ans vous avez travaillé dans dans
le froid dans les intempéries apporter
des charges lourdes à partir de 60 ans à
partir de 62 ans vous êtes éreinté
fatigué laminé vous n'existez plus
physiquement et vous dites que l'on peut
encore continuer de travailler deux ans
supplémentaires et tout à l'heure le
collègue sénateur je regardais sa page
wikipédia j'ai pas réussi à trouver son
travail mais je pense pas vous allez
travailler avec ses mains pendant 40 ans
pour avoir cet avis là et pensez aussi
aux personnes que vous applaudissiez
tous que nous applaudissions tous à 20h
il y a deux ans les soignants les
infirmières les médecins les
aides-soignantes les ash comment vous
pouvez oser les regarder encore
aujourd'hui et vous Mesdames et
Messieurs les médecins quand vous les
recevez dans vos cabinets que vous que
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites quant à 62
ans les les aides-soignants vous dites
vous disent mais moi je peux plus faire
les transferts des personnes âgées du
brancard à un lit parce que j'ai le dos
cassé j'ai les bras cassés j'ai les
épaules cassés vous leur dites quoi vous
leur dites ben écoutez vous allez quand
même faire deux ans supplémentaires
c'est ça mais comment vous vous pouvez
tenir de tels propos comment pouvez-vous
ne pas être d'accord avec nous quand
nous disons que pour ces gens-là pas
pour tout le monde pas pour tout le
monde moi maintenant aujourd'hui je peux
tout à fait travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
jusqu'à 65 ans rassurez-vous c'est bien
moins pénible d'être ici même jusqu'à 2h
du matin à 3h du matin 4h du matin que
faire paysan ou travailler dans le
bâtiment rassurez-vous moi j'ai fait
tous ces métiers là et je peux vous
garantir que ces métiers là l'ont du
plan anti-âge de la tête vous achetez de
la tête chers collègues sénateur mais
vous savez très bien que j'ai raison
vous avez très bien comment propose est
vrai merci
la présidente la présidente Catherine de
roche a demandé la parole
président
vous rappelez quand même que nous sommes
dans un débat qui certes en effet peut
être passionné et c'est normal puisque
on est sur un tel sujet bon les attaques
à nominales sur les fiches des uns des
autres c'est pas forcément utile
néanmoins néanmoins je vous avais parlé
beaucoup pénibilité là depuis quelques
minutes je vous rappelle que si vous
voulez qu'on avance sur l'article sur la
pénibilité il faudrait peut-être
resserrer le temps l'article 7 veut être
discuter demain après-midi donc acte je
veux bien mais au rythme on va c'est
même pas demain après-midi je veux dire
un moment il faut aussi quand on prend
des engagements les respecter
bien je vous propose de passer au vote
sur l'amendement 2881 qui vient d'être
présenté par le groupe socialiste qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement
3166 présenté par Madame concemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors lors
de la présentation de ce projet de
réforme la première ministre Madame
Elisabeth borne admis lors de cette
présentation le Dijon janvier de
nombreuses entreprises ont recours à une
pratique abusive voire discriminatoire
qui consiste à faire partir les salariés
quelques années avant la retraite
et donc et donc rien voilà assis l'index
voilà donc une forme d'impuissance
l'État serait impuissant devant ça et
effectivement vu qu'il y a les moyens de
contrôle de l'inspection du travail de
toute façon sur des pratiques je répète
abusives voire discriminatoire étant ce
qu'elles sont cela continuera alors non
effectivement nous nous pensons que il
faut il faut contrôler il faut aussi
sanctionner
les entreprises qui se débarrassent
effectivement des salariés quelques
années avant la retraite alors on nous a
dit la contribution de la lande avait
cette motivation ça a vraiment pas
marché et ce qu'on nous a dit aussi
c'est ça a pas marché et les entreprises
elles ont licencié un an avant bon donc
le comportement des entreprises là étant
ce qu'il est vous voyez mais c'était la
preuve qu'il fallait pas de pénalité
parce que les entreprises licencieraient
avant donc maintenant on nous propose
peut-être de leur donner quelque chose
une prime une exonération pour pas
qu'elle le fasse c'est-à-dire qu'on
navigue entre un puissance sur un
comportement condamnable et effet
d'aubaine alors non je pense que
effectivement les entreprises ont une
grande responsabilité dans le maintien
en emploi des seigneurs et dans un
contexte effectivement ou beaucoup
considèrent le Seigneur comme des
salariés qui peuvent pas suivre
l'intensification du travail c'est
terminé donc il faut il faut dépénaliser
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
avis défavorable donc double avis
défavorable je le soumets aux voix qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement
2515 monsieur broyier ainsi Michel
Président Monsieur monsieur le ministre
chers collègue cet amendement est
inspiré par notre ancienne collègue
Sophie tailler paulian dont j'ai pris la
suite et par les députés écologistes
elle vise à instaurer un malus sur les
cotisations écoutez bien avant de rire
sur les cotisations des employeurs pas
de tous les employeurs mais sur les
cotisations du titre des accidents du
travail et des maladies professionnelles
uniquement pour les entreprises qui
présentent une tendance élevée au
licenciement de travailleurs et de
travailleuses pour inaptitude l'objectif
j'espère que ça ne fait moins rire
l'objectif est multiple inciter les
entreprises à s'engager sur des
politiques opérantes de prévention des
accidents et maladies professionnelles
et éviter au maximum les déclarations
d'inaptitude
s'assurer que les hypothèses de
reclassement sont bel et bien étudiées
au maximum respectés et ainsi limiter au
maximum les licenciements pour
inaptitude faire contribuer davantage au
financement de la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle des
entreprises moins responsables qui
licencie pour inaptitude des salariés
qui seront ensuite pris en charge par la
Sécurité Sociale d'après l'enquête
Emploi 2012 en 5 ans le taux de
licenciement pour inaptitude a fortement
augmenté il est passé de 4 à 6
licenciements pour 1000 emplois en CDI
50% d'augmentation si le chiffre de 100
000 salariés déclarés inapte à leur
poste et régulièrement avancée de façon
parcellaire il n'existe aucun chiffre au
niveau national qui est consolide ce
phénomène ainsi ce dispositif
permettrait en outre d'avoir une vision
globale et des données sur le nombre
d'entreprises qui ont recours à des
licenciements pour inaptitude cet
amendement renvoie à une définition
réglementaire nécessaire précisant le
taux anormalement élevé de licenciement
qui avant de passer à la vie de la
commission je vous signale j'ai une
demande de scrutin public du groupe
écologie sur cet amendement avis de la
commission
avis de la commission allez-y monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement dans l'exposé des motifs
on parle de l'inaptitude au travail qui
est une préoccupation quand même majeure
mais là l'amendement vous parlez de
faire des modifications des pénalités
sur la branche ATMP ça mérite de
souligner la différence inaptitude au
travail n'est pas prise en compte comme
l'incapacité permanente qui elle relève
de la branche ATMP qui concerne la
pénibilité quand les salariés sont
exposés au travail quand une usure au
travail à travers les facteurs de
pénibilité qu'il soit pris en compte sur
le C2P qui soit ergonomique qui soit
jean-chimique tandis quand il y a une
inaptitude de travail ça peut être par
une maladie par d'autres dispositifs ce
n'est pas pris en charge dans le cas de
la branche ATMP faut bien faire la
différence parce que les prises en
charge sont réellement différentes c'est
la raison pour laquelle la branche ATMP
n'étant pas concernée par les problèmes
d'inaptitude nous avons donné un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre
donc un avis défavorable également de
monsieur le ministre monsieur Fernique
une explication de vote je crois que le
phénomène des salariés inapte au travail
fait vraiment l'objet d'une
sous-évaluation par les pouvoirs publics
il existe aucun chiffre national
consolidé du nombre d'avis d'inaptitude
attribué vers la médecine du travail à
ces salariés qui ne peuvent pas
reprendre totalement ou parce qu'elles
ment leur emplois initial pourtant plus
de 90% des salariés déclarés inaps sont
licenciés selon un rapport de la Haute
Autorité de Santé la reconnaissance de
cette inaptitude permet de toucher une
indemnité en capital selon le taux
d'incapacité une rente d'incapacité
versée par la Sécurité Sociale chaque
trimestre pour les incapacités
inférieures à 50%. c'est 30 pour
inaptitude qui n'excède pas 25% de leur
salaire de référence est jugé
unanimement faible et ne permet pas de
vivre une fois l'indemnité en capital et
les droits au chômage consommé ainsi en
estimait en 2017 à 100 000 nouveaux
salariés inaptent inscrits chaque année
à Pôle emploi et à 1 à 2 millions le
nombre total de salariés qui seraient
menacés de désinsertion profession un
phénomène qui ne cesse de se renforcer
en raison du report de l'âge de départ à
la retraite car il touche
particulièrement les salariés seniors
ayant eu des métiers physiques et
intervient en moyenne à 60,4 ans pour
les hommes et à 65,9 ans pour les femmes
est une dresse de 2020 même un faible
degré d'inaptitude peut poser
d'importantes difficultés d'insertion
seul 25% des salariés inaptent sont
employés vers des structures sont
envoyées pardon vers des structures
spécialisées dans l’insertion de
travailleurs en situation de handicap et
les conseillers Pôle Emploi ça vous
démuni face à certains cas les réformes
successives de l'assurance chômage sont
venus durcir les conditions
d'indemnisation sans égard pour les
centaines de milliers de salariés qui ne
peuvent plus accéder à la grande
majorité des postes proposées et enfin
pour conclure je dirais que la question
écologique est également à prendre en
considération dans la mesure où les
risques professionnels sont largement
liés aux dangers de la pollution encore
des produits chimiques merci de votre
attention
merci donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
écologique sur cet amendement 2515 avec
un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà on continue à examiner des
propositions venues de la gauche de
l'hémicycle sur des mesures alternatives
de financement de notre régime des
retraites par répartition là on voit par
exemple l'idée d'un malus sur les
cotisations des employeurs du au titre
des accidents du travail et proposer par
les écologistes dans l'hémicycle et donc
un scrutin public et donc demandé par ce
groupe de gauche aussi pour ralentir un
peu les débats au lieu de voter par main
levée on vote avec des cartes
électroniques dans l'hémicycle et donc
on voit tout ces échanges entre à la
gauche et la droite mais surtout surtout
la gauche qui prend la parole pour
proposer ces alternatives dans le
financement du régime des retraites la
cloche sonne et résonne dans les
couloirs du Palais du Luxembourg c'est
que le résultat va du scrutin va être
annoncé on retourne dans l'hémicycle
donc deux amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune le premier le
Monsieur Madame poncemonge madame ponce
je crois que le deuxième aussi
3488 donc peut-être vous pouvez
présenter les deux ils sont en
discussion commune
merci monsieur le Président oui je
prends acte de la remarque effectivement
en lisant le dispositif de du rapporteur
donc je lui donne une occasion de
effectivement de d'avoir un avis
défavorable sur mon amendement parce que
c'est pas à la TNT mais effectivement
l'assurance maladie qu'il faudrait
verser des les pénalités autrement il
doit le regretter il aurait très
certainement approuvé le fait que il
faut alors instaurer une pénalité pas
tant pour parce que on parlait de l'aide
à domicile tout à l'heure et les aides à
domicile désormais partout quel que soit
les organisations fut-elles les plus
vertueuses sortent par inaptitude
massivement alors elle sortiront encore
plus demain avec deux ans de plus mais
surtout sur le fait des entreprises qui
ne font aucun effort enfin qui n'ont pas
un plan soit de prévention ou d'action
pour y remédier c'est à dire il suffit
là pour le coup d'aller voir dans la
durée pour faire pour ceux qui
connaissent la déclaration unique si
effectivement il y a des actions quand
même de l'entreprise essayons d'être
vertueux par rapport à un risque élevé
dans certaines branches donc c'est
toujours relativement à une branche
qu'il faut faire ça et moi ce que
j'aimerais dire quand même c'est que le
licenciement par inaptitude est dû aussi
aujourd'hui au fait que dans les
entreprises on a beaucoup externalisé
les postes qui étaient allégés pour des
raisons de comparatifs de moins 10 ans
de coups quoi et désormais il y a que
les postes les plus durs donc il est
difficile même pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient mais c'est la conséquence
de cette stratégie d'externalisation
par rapport à une politique de moins 10
ans et à ce propos il faut bien dire que
quelquefois on compare le coût dans les
fonctions publiques des fonctionnaires
par rapport au privé et bien le privé
externalisent le coût social de ces de
ces salariés qui ont des difficultés à
suivre un petit peu le poste de travail
le privé externaliste sur la société et
de la fonction publique quelle qu'elle
soit dans les trois ordres les gardes
essaient de trouver des postes adaptées
alors quelques fois ces deux-là que
vient le différentiel de coups quand on
veut privatiser certains services de la
fonction publique
vous avez présenté les deux amants de
monde donc Madame poncer mon jean ok
habits de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements
merci répond de penser bon je vous avais
bien compris le dispositif que
l'inaptitude effectivement correspondait
à l'assurance maladie et que c'était la
capacité permanente qui correspondait à
la TP mais
Raymonde permettez-moi de vous dire
qu'il y a quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut rétablir on ne prend pas deux ans
de plus par l'inaptitude le la retraite
anticipée pour une aptitude aujourd'hui
est à 62 ans c'est l'âge légal demain
dans la loi la retraite par aptitude
sera sur un agent anticipé 64 - 2 mais
restera 62 ans
j'aurais préféré qu'on voit les choses
différemment parce que je partage vos
préoccupations sur l'inaptitude j'aurais
bien essayé de descendre un petit peu là
je mets monsieur le ministre m'a dit que
ce serait pas raisonnable et il me
fallait son avis pour effectivement
sortir du droit actuel voilà tandis que
l'incapacité permanente qui vous
préoccupe vous allez voir qu'on fait des
propositions et on par rapport aux
propositions de Monsieur le Ministre et
qui m'en veut beaucoup parce que ça va
coûter un peu de sous donc j'ai besoin
de son autorisation je voudrais la
descendre à 60 ans voyez-vous le droit
actuel quand même qui oui à 60 ans - 2
vous voyez pour rester dans le
dispositif actuel mais si vous avez
cette impatience
de délibérer sur l'inaptitude de
délibérer sur l'incapacité permanente
attendez l'article 8 et l'article 9 et
invançons dans les débats parce que ça
c'est une préoccupation de nos
concitoyens
[Applaudissements]
avis de monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie du gouvernement madame
ponçait
oui monsieur le rapporteur mais j'étais
sur l'inaptitude que vous l'avez dit
qu'il relève de l'assurance maladie et
pas sur l'incapacité permanente mais
vous avez raison pour l'incapacité
permanente il n'y a pas de changement
il pouvait partir à 62 ans ils peuvent
toujours partir à 62 ans c'est pourquoi
effectivement ce n'est pas une mesure
d'accompagnement messieurs les ministres
et donc en aucun cas ils doivent être
marqués comme venant se soustraire des
18 milliards que vous allez économiser
soit par la baisse des pensions soit par
les apports contributifs de ce laitier
qui continueront à travailler donc par
contre si vous passez si vous entendez
le rapporteur général et que vous passez
l'incapacité permanente à 60 ans Alors
là Monsieur le Ministre ça sera une
mesure d'accompagnement et vous pourrez
déduire les 3 milliards que vous avez
indument mis sur une sur une mesure qui
n'est que le maintien et qui n'est en
aucun cas un seul coup
bien merci donc sur ces deux amendements
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public
oui par le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire sur le
premier de ces deux amendements
l'amendement 3174 avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 de règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
voilà nous sommes toujours sur la même
série d'amendements cet amendement vise
à instaurer un malus pour les
entreprises qui présentent une tendance
élevée à licencier des travailleurs et
des travailleurs dit l'objet de cet
amendement lorsqu'on le consulte sur le
site du Sénat donc les écologistes qui
déposent des propositions de financement
alternatifs à la réforme des retraites
et qui risque très fort de voir ces
amendements rejetés avec les mêmes
ratios que depuis le début de ses
scrutin public c'est-à-dire la gauche
qui se compte autour de 91 voix et la
droite c'est le centre qui réunissent
autour de 250 scrutins sur ses
amendements venus de la gauche on va
aller écouter le résultat du scrutin
dans l'hémicycle 343 exprimer 342 pour
91 contre 251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
est-ce que je peux considérer que nous
avons le même vote sur le
3488 qui a été présenté en même temps
oui donc même vote
nous passons ensuite à l'amendement
2461 monsieur Ferney
et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je remplace la Thomas docius
notre collègue qui propose au nom du
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
s'est amendement qui vise à créer une
contribution exceptionnelle pour les
entreprises qui enregistreraient un taux
de licenciement pour inaptilus supérieur
à la moyenne de la branche concernée en
ce qui concerne leurs salariés de plus
de 59 ans la situation professionnelle
des seniors est souvent critique on l'a
compris de nombreux salariés depuis de
55 ans sont mis à la porte du jour au
lendemain par leurs employeurs
respectifs sans raison apparente je
rappelle après ma collègue Raymonde que
la première ministre Elisabeth borne l'a
d'ailleurs ici même à 1000 lors de la
présentation du projet de réforme
qualifiant cette pratique qui consiste à
faire partir les salariés quelques
années avant la retraite je cite
d'abusive voire de discriminatoires
c'est elle qui le disait ces employés
licenciés peinent à retrouver du travail
et font face à tout un tas de préjugés
les employeurs craignent utiliser des
problèmes de santé ou qu'ils demandent
une rémunération trop importante
résultat d'après une récente étude de la
DARES le taux d'emploi des 54 64 ans
s'élève à 56 en France 56 56% pardon en
France un chiffre bien en dessous de la
moyenne européenne qui est au-dessus de
60 selon vous monsieur le ministre la
réforme des retraites favoriserait
l'emploi des travailleurs seniors et
donc le plein emploi en réalité la
réforme exclura du marché du travail
c'est même travailleur c'est le constat
qui a été fait à chaque décalage de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
comme avec la réforme verte en 2010
ainsi en 2019 16% des personnes de plus
de 50 ans n'étaient ni en emploi ni à la
retraite pour ces personnes décalées là
je légale c'est simplement être plus
longtemps au chômage ou au minima
sociaux ça a été dit la situation des
plus de 59 ans va donc s'aggraver
contrairement à ce que Monsieur le
Ministre votre gouvernement essaie de
nous faire croire parce que cette
situation est insupportable nous
proposons donc d'instaurer une
contribution exceptionnelle dans le but
de
dissuader les entreprises de licencier
leurs employés depuis 50 ans neuf ans de
manière abusive merci avis de la
commission
oui merci là encore l'exposé des motifs
ne correspond pas à l'objet de
l'amendement
faudrait prendre pour habitude quand
même ce que nous pratiquons
régulièrement c'est à dire présenter nos
amendements en fonction de l'objet là il
s'agit de pénalité qui est à la cnaval
ce qui est pas mal ça renforé le budget
de la CNAV mais des pénalités
supplémentaires pour les en pour les
entreprises qui enregistrent un taux de
licenciement pour inaptitude donc c'est
bien la CNAV il y a pas de problème
inaptitude des salariés plus de 59 ans
supérieur à la moyenne de leur branche
peut arriver qu'il y ait des accidents
et si un taux d'inaptitude à 58 ans ils
sont pas concernés par la mesure à 59
ans on discutait des effets de bornes
j'ai cru comprendre tout à l'heure vous
étiez pas
tellement intéressé par les bornes en
tout cas on critique les bornes quand ça
nous plaît pas mais on en fait l'éloge
quelques minutes après en conséquence
nous avons nous la même cohérence donc
avis défavorable pour des pénalités
supplémentaires nous pensons qu'il vaut
mieux faire des plans de prévention de
l'inaptitude
avis de Monsieur le Ministre
donc même avis double avis défavorable
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe écologiste sur
l'amendement
2461 avec un double avis défavorable
il va être procédé au vote dans ce que
dans les conditions etc le scrutin est
ouvert
voilà nous sommes toujours dans un
scrutin public provoqué par la gauche de
l'hémicycle encore une fois sur et bien
une proposition pour un site instaurer
une contribution pardon exceptionnelle
dans le but de dissuader les entreprises
de licencié leur employés de plus de 59
ans de manière abusive c'est l'objet de
cet amendement sur lequel est en train
de voter le Sénat à l'heure où je vous
parle et la gauche qui multiplie les
demandes de scrutin public qui donc
ralentit le débat même chose avec les
explications de vote et ce dépôt massif
d'amendement on voit que c'est une
stratégie pour occuper le terrain durant
nous la part de la gauche retour dans
l'hémicycle 143 exprimé 342 pour 90
contre 252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
ensuite deux amendements discussions
identiques en discussion commune le
2875 madame briquet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain visa
visa financé le fond pour la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle dans les
hôpitaux et établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux par un malus de
cotisation patronales sur
l'accidentologie au travail aujourd'hui
nous savons tous nos hôpitaux manquent
de personnel et peine aujourd'hui à
recruter du fait aussi de la pénibilité
un des métiers concernés
ce malus ne serait qu'un juste retour
des choses pour améliorer les conditions
de travail dans ce secteur
particulièrement sensible et au combien
indispensable pour nos concitoyens
merci et donc amendement identique le
3171 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors comme
c'est de nouveau un malus et avons je
vais m'abriter derrière le rapport de la
Cour des comptes sur les politiques de
prévention en santé au travail dans les
entreprises un rapport de décembre 2022
qui critique le manque d'ambition de la
politique publique donc de l'État en
matière de santé au travail et de
prévention des risques professionnels et
je le cite l'absence de contraintes qui
pèse sur les entreprises bien donc si la
Cour des comptes le dit je m'autorise à
le dire aussi je ne reviens pas sur les
chiffres quand même des contraintes de
la DARES vous avez cité la DARES sur les
contraintes physiques et aussi des
contraintes de rythme de travail
mais si je reviens pas sur sur ces
chiffres quand même j'espère monsieur le
rapporteur que
quand nous discuterons de l'article sur
la pénibilité
on verra s'ils sont les mesures les
propositions que vous faites s'ils sont
à la hauteur de l'explosion
multiplication par 3 ou multiplices par
4 quel que soit les catégories
socio-professionnelles de ces
contraintes de pénibilité physique et de
contraintes temporelles parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut voir c'est un est-ce qu'il
tienne compte de cette explosion et de
est-ce que la population qui est quand
même plus vulnérable et moins résistante
je dirais devant ces contraintes
physiques et contraintes temporaires qui
vont devoir temporels d'envoir
travailler de 62 à 64 ans est-ce que
seront en mesure de rester dans
l'activité du travail je vous remercie
si avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements
rapport avec la branche ATMP donc même
motif même sanction votre avis
défavorable ou
Raymond poncemont je n'hésitais pas à le
retirer si vous le souhaitez
mais ma vie de Monsieur le Ministre donc
je vais soumettre aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques et pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
je passe à l'amendement
2329 présenté par Monsieur Hainaut oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on est d'accord au fond au
travers ce débat de considérer que
l'emploi des seniors est une question
essentielle et c'est un amendement qui
résulte d'une discussion avec un patron
éclairé avec des préoccupations sociales
et donc ce qui est évoqué c'est la
question de l'exonération on aurait
préféré la prime mais ok pour
l'exonération mais que se passe-t-il
notamment quand il y a rupture
d'engagement et donc je sais pas si
c'est un amendement d'appel si c'est un
amendement qui veut lancer le débat mais
entendre le rapporteur sur cette
question que se passe-t-il en cas de la
rupture d'engagement si le CDI ne va pas
à son terme et il me paraîtrait
judicieux ça n'est pas une sanction
c'est la logique du juste retour que les
exonérations dont attiré le bénéfice
l'entreprise puisse être remboursée au
cas où il n'y aurait pas respect des
engagements qui ont été pris à
l'embauche je vous remercie et je ne
veux m'interroger aussi de savoir s'il
faut légiférer deuxième question que je
veux aborder puisque étant attaché au
paritarisme et à la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux bien évidemment si
on aborde toutes les questions
législatives et de droit dans une
logique d'entonnoir alors on laisse pas
suffisamment de grains à moudre au
partenaire sociaux voilà le l'objet de
cet amendement qui veut poser sur la
table tous ces sujets je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci Olivier et nous il y a des
questions et les réponses à l'intérieur
de l'intervention mais le sujet
effectivement est celui-là vous proposez
déplacer les bornes à 57 ans alors déjà
monsieur le ministre tous je dirais
entre guillemets par rapport à nos
propositions qui sont estimées à un prix
probibitif quand on met l'âge de 60 ans
vous pensez à 57 ans effectivement ça
devient là un peu plus encore effet
d'aubaine si effets d'aubaine il y a à
vérifier le CDI senior est en train un
CDI différent du CDI classique il
appartiendra au partenaires sociaux de
le préciser justement pour marquer la
différence parce que sinon je partage
l'effet d'aubaine donc faut bien marquer
la différence et ensuite effectivement
c'est le dispositif
qui pourrait être intéressant si vous
bénéficiez d'exonération que vous tenez
pas l'engagement pour tenir votre
salarié jusqu'à ce qu'il soit au taux
plein ou à l'âge d'annulation de la
décote mais quelque part l'engagement
pas tenu et il peut y avoir
répercussions et remboursement des
exonérations dont on a bénéficié
cependant je pense que véritablement et
c'était la fin de votre intervention qui
vaut mieux laisser les partenaires
sociaux délibérés là-dessus et puis
ensuite prendre nos responsabilités et
nous aurons l'occasion de prendre nos
responsabilités puisque le monsieur le
ministre du travail s'est engagé à nous
présenter la loi travail après les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
à travers la nid mais également à
travers d'autres dispositifs notamment
l'intéressement je crois que c'est comme
ça que l'on dit de salariés par rapport
à l'entreprise qui est là aussi quelque
chose qui peut être pertinent et
différencier en fonction des seniors
s'il y a une réelle volonté des
entreprises d'aller dans dans cette
politique des seniors donc je demanderai
olivierno de retirer son amendement en
attendant ces discussions négociation
même je dirais avec les partenaires
sociaux
sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président encore une
fois moi j'entends l'intention et on est
tous là pour évidemment chercher des
mesures pour favoriser l'emploi des
seniors mais j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
à l'occasion de la présentation de
l'amendement sur le CDI senior que je
suis réservé notamment sur les
exonérations de cotisation qui sont
liées à un âge donné là en l'occurrence
c'est 57 ans on voit bien que le risque
c'est que ça décale entre guillemets le
problème et qu'un salarié de 55 56 ans
qui se présente dans une entreprise
l'entreprise lui dise bah revenez dans
un an ou dans deux ans puisque vous
aurez 57 ans et à ce moment-là vous
donnerez droit à une exonération et donc
le salarié en question il se retrouve à
devoir attendre et il aura des
difficultés à trouver un emploi avant
d'atteindre 57 ans par ailleurs c'est
vrai que ça aurait un coût certain
chiffré à 3 milliards 6 avec cet
amendement mais je pense que à travers
votre amendement vous voulez surtout
entre guillemets alerter et provoquer la
discussion sur des mesures sur l'emploi
des seniors et ça me permet de vous
répondre sur le fait que mon collègue
Olivier du socle présentera bien au
printemps prochain la loi travail et que
le sujet de l'emploi des seniors fera
évidemment partie des travaux que vous
conduirez dans le cadre de ce texte
merci Monsieur Hainaut retirez
donc il est retiré
on continue avec l'amendement
124 rectifier bis qui présentait à les
émotions
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement de ma collègue Dominique
estrasiason propose d'exonérer de
cotisations vieillesse à la charge de
l'employeur la rémunération versée aux
salariés qui font le choix de continuer
de travailler dès lors qu'ils ont cet
endroit de liquider leur retraite parce
qu'on peut très bien faire le choix de
continuer de travailler malgré le fait
qu'on est passé là je de liquider ses
droits à la retraite ça peut être bon
pour le salarié dans son épanouissement
personnel mais ça peut être bon pour
l'entreprise à la fois pour un tuilage
ou à la fois pour pouvoir sauvegarder
une continuité dans l'activité il est à
la fois un outil pour accompagner
certaines fin de carrière et une
incitation pour les employeurs à
recruter des seniors avec une baisse du
coût de travail il favorise également la
transition entre l'emploi et la retraite
pour des salariés qui ne souhaitent pas
partir dès lors qu'ils le peuvent
et enfin en exonérant de ses cotisations
les salariés seniors l'emploi sera
stimulé au sein des entreprises et il
travaille
permettant de créer d'éventuelles
embauches avec les économies réalisées
merci merci Monsieur Ritman monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur Ritman j'ai été très
intéressé par cet amendement et nous
avons essayé de travailler dessus pour
voir comment on pouvait effectivement le
traduire il pose véritablement un effet
de seuil lui aussi selon l'âge et
surtout un effet d'aubaine parce que
ceux qui sont des gens en emploi
pourraient effectivement bénéficier de
cette exonération contenu de la
déclaration de la personne qui part en
retraite mais si elle revient derrière
le départ en retraite actuellement n'est
pas une norme législatif donc on peut
pas s'appuyer dessus c'est la raison
pour laquelle on appartenu sinon c'est
un effet d'aubaine sinon c'est un effet
domaine c'est pour ça que je vous
demanderai le retirer mais nous avions
songé à la commission justement pour
avoir une cohérence dans nos mesures par
rapport à la surcote que nous accordions
au maire de famille il lui était
intéressant pour celles qui veulent
rester aussi au travail et justement
acquérir
améliorer encore leur futur retraite
qu'elle puisse bénéficier de que
l'employeur puisse bénéficier d'une
exonération pour l'inciter à continuer
justement un petit peu au travail mais
on ne peut pas s'appliquer sur un
dispositif législatif on peut pas créer
comme ça parce que c'est pas une norme
en conséquence ça mérite une réflexion
venant à la fois du ministère et des
partenaires sociaux là aussi on renvoie
à la loi travail donc merci de retirer
l'amendement monsieur le ministre
à nouveau je remercie Monsieur Ritman et
Madame Estrosi Sassone qui est la
première signataire de la maman c'est un
débat absolument majeur je m'inscris
dans ce cas dit le rapporteur d'un point
de vue juridique j'ajoute aussi qu'il y
a un certain coût qui adore déjà
aujourd'hui des exonérations générales
qui bénéficient au Seigneur jusqu'à 2,5
et le bandeau maladie et même jusqu'à
3,5 bandeau famille et que donc ces
exonérations supplémentaires sera
confortées ça serait concentré
finalement sur un petit nombre de
seniors ceux qui ont la rémunération la
plus importante et je suis pas sûr que
pour eux la question l'exonération de
cotisation soit le moteur principal dans
le recrutement mais ça fera partie des
sujets qui seront abordés à l'occasion
de la loi travail
il est retiré merci
[Musique]
amendement 4639 madame chilinger
est un amendement d'appel alors que le
taux d'emploi des seigneurs en France
reste inférieurs à celui de la moyenne
européenne le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite implique un risque
de précarisation des travailleurs de
plus de 55 ans ce risque pèse
particulièrement sur les femmes qui sont
plus sujettes aux carrières hachées et
de ce fait plus exposé au risque de ne
pas pouvoir justifier de l'ensemble de
leurs trimestre au moment de leur départ
à la retraite en conséquence le
reportage légal doit s'accompagner de
mesures sociales fortes en faveur de
l'emploi des seigneurs aussi
l'amendement proposé vise à favoriser
l'embauche et salariés de plus de 55 ans
via l'allègement des cotisations
sociales relatives à l'assurance
vieillesse
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui effectivement merci d'avoir proposé
cet amendement mais alors dans le groupe
majoritaire je pensais que vous étiez
sensible au rendement de l'équilibre de
cette réforme des retraites parce que
nous c'est l'argument qu'on nous met
sans cesse en face des propositions que
l'on fait donc le but de la réforme
étant de combler les déficits et pas les
creuser je pense que si nous avons une
largesse d'allant jusque 55 ans Monsieur
le Ministre des comptes publics va
tomber du fauteuil en conséquence je
vous demande de retirer l'amendement
sachant que il y a d'autres dispositifs
qui permettent de maintenir les emplois
en seniors et que là effectivement les
exonérations je peux partager bien
entendu le raisonnement monsieur le
ministre porterait surtout pour les
salaires les plus élevés par rapport au
salaire les plus bas qui sont déjà
tournés par les exonérations merci de le
retirer sur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président je
rassurais le rapporteur madame chilinger
me fera jamais tomber du fauteuil on est
évidemment bien accroché avec elle je
veux la remercier je vais vous remercier
madame la sénatrice pour là aussi
contribuer au débat sur cette question
de l'emploi des seniors qui est
absolument majeur moi je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je suis réservé sur les
exonérations de cotisation qui sont
liées à un âge donné puisque le risque
c'est qu'il y a un effet de seuil et que
ceux qui sont juste en dessous de l'âge
se retrouvent entre guillemets les ai
par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il y a un
certain coût un point de baisse de
cotisation c'est un milliard donc là
votre amendement ne fixe pas le nombre
de points de baisse qui renvoie un
décret enfin c'est un coût certain pour
un effet plus incertain sur l'emploi
mais je vous remercie d'avoir porté le
débat qui se produira qui se prolongera
dans la loi travail donc je propose le
retrait de l'amendement
le but c'était vraiment de d'évoquer ce
sujet là merci donc il est retiré
ensuite deux amendements en discussion
commune le 3150 4 madame Poncet Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors là
c'est relatif cette amendement est
relatif aux mesures de la loi sur le
partage de la valeur qui sont exonérés
de cotisations et contributions sociales
et défiscalisée monsieur le ministre
vous étiez content ça rencontre
paraît-il un grand succès d'ailleurs ça
m'étonne pas plus de 5 millions de
bénéficiaires OK et je rappelle que la
prime ainsi des socialisée défiscalisés
peut aller jusqu'à 6000 euros mais
surtout surtout elle n'est pas compensée
par l'État auprès des caisses de la
Sécurité sociale nous avions déposé un
amendement exigeant l'application de la
loi Veil qui avait été
votée par notre notre chambre il a sauté
en CMP je suppose par suite à votre
intervention cela représente donc une
perte de recettes sensibles pour les
contes de la sécurité sociale là c'est
c'est net et se substit-il à des AGS qui
eux elles auraient été pérennes je vous
passe la démonstration qui effectivement
c'est un effet de substitution
d'augmentation des
un simple effet de substitution ce qu'on
appelle aussi un effet d'aubaine mais
les salariés justement sont en train de
faire le lien entre la cotisation et les
droits et c'est très bien qu'il le fasse
parce que ce salaire socialisé dont vous
leur faites cadeaux enfin en disant que
vous les taxez pas paraît-il et bien
c'est une perte de recettes pour la
protection sociale d'autant quand elles
sont pas compensées c'est le cas ici et
quelque part vous leur présentez la
facture c'est quelques mois de travail
en plus puisque vous asséchez des
recettes et donc vous ferez déficit
quant aux salariés lui aussi il vient de
s'apercevoir aussi que de ne pas avoir
ce salaire socialisé c'est un cadeau à
court terme mais une perte à long terme
parce que tout comme les fonctionnaires
il s'aperçoivent que les primes des
socialisés et des fonctionnalités et des
fiscalisés ne compte pas dans la pension
et participent à la baisse tendance des
pensions donc voilà tous voulons
remettre dans l'application du droit
c'est terminé madame j'ai terminé merci
président
le 4475 monsieur Baki merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les ministres cet
amendements pointe le double discours du
gouvernement qui prétend vouloir à la
fois sauver le régime répartition ou
empêcher la faillite du système mais en
même temps qui s'attache à chaque
occasion à soustraire aux cotisations
les éléments de rémunération octroyés
aux travailleurs les mesures nouvelles
récemment prises n'auraient pas d'impact
sur les recettes de la sécurité sociale
nous le disons le principe c'est que
tout travail mérite salaire et toute
cotisations et du salaire par ce
postulat les heures supplémentaires
coûteraient 200 millions d'euros en
année pleine en 2023 mais la
monétisation des RTT qui procède de la
même finalité serait elle sans impact
financier selon le même raisonnement la
prime Macron mal nommé partage de la
valeur
car désocialiser ne pèserait sur les
finances de la sécurité sociale elle
constitue par nature mais par nature
pardonne l'effet d'éviction du salaire
et devrait de ce fait se voir appliquer
le taux de cotisation par défaut
appliqué à chaque tranche de salaire
pour calculer le manque à gagner de
cette forme de rémunération au détriment
du salaire ne propagez pas monsieur le
ministre l'idée que les cotisations sont
soutirés au travailleur et qu'elle est
prise de revenus les cotisations sont du
salaire partageons la valeur en entier
jusqu'au moindre euro en somme
soumettons aux cotisations chaque euro
versé aux travailleuses et au
travailleur
merci donc sur ces deux amendements la
vie de Madame la rapporteur oui ces deux
amendements proposent finalement de
vider de son contenu le dispositif de de
comment de prime de partage de la valeur
de la valeur qui a été je le rappelle
mis en place assez récemment finalement
puisque ça date du 22 août dernier
en réalité et bien on ne prendrait pas
en considération le nombre d'entreprises
et le nombre de salariés dont on vient
de parler monsieur le ministre qui
bénéficie de cette prime si à certains
tel succès c'est bien que actuellement
c'est un plus pour un certain nombre de
salariés mais aussi pour de familles
donc c'est un avis défavorable
sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président en fait ce
sont des amendements qui visent à mettre
fin à la prime de partage de la valeur
ou à la prime Macron
puisque si vous et c'est ce que propose
ces amendements si vous leur appliquez
le même niveau le niveau de cotisation
sociale général auranement ça veut dire
que vous mettez en place un niveau de
cotisation sociale jusqu'à 60 points
et donc pour une prime à 1000 euros qui
est versé par l'entreprise à un salarié
ça veut dire qu'il faut payer 600 euros
jusqu'à 600 euros de cotisation autant
dire qu'il y a plus de primes moi je
rappelle quand même que cette prime l'an
dernier elle a bénéficié à 5 millions
500 000 salariés 4 milliards 500
millions d'euros qui ont été partagés
avec 5 millions 500 000 salariés dont 2
millions dans des entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés et les primes les plus
importantes étaient dans les TPE donc
c'est pas pour des cadres des grands
groupes les primes les plus importantes
étaient dans des TPE vous dites le
versement de ces primes défiscaliser des
socialisés se fait au détriment du
financement de la protection sociale je
suis pas d'accord avec ça parce que
c'est des outils qui sont précisément
mis à la disposition d'entreprises qui
en raison de l'incertitude économique ne
peuvent pas augmenter les salaires parce
qu'elles s'engagerait sur des charges
supplémentaires pour les années à venir
sans savoir ce que sera la situation
économique et donc il précisément
peuvent donner une prime à des salariés
donc c'est pas la prime ou du salaire
c'est bien souvent la ou rien et donc ça
ne se fait pas au détriment du
financement de la protection sociale ça
ne se fait qu'au bénéfice de la
rémunération du salarié de son pouvoir
d'achat donc avis défavorable
aucun double avis défavorable monsieur
gay
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues merci de
ces chiffres monsieur monsieur le
ministre c'est un million de salariés en
moyenne 800 euros je crois 789 en
moyenne donc ça veut dire que un il y
avait pas besoin d'une loi cet été pour
doubler le plafond puisque le plafond
était déjà 1000 euros donc 2000 on voit
que ça a rien agi non mais non mais
c'est ça la réalité monsieur monsieur le
ministre deuxièmement cinq millions de
salariés certes mais il y en a combien
en France plus de 26 millions c'est à
dire que 18% des salariés touchent ce
qu'on appelle la prime de la partage ou
la prime Macron peu importe et 82% des
salariés ils ont touché quoi
ben pas grand chose
donc la question de l'augmentation des
salaires elle est bien posée pour
l'ensemble des salariés y compris ceux
qui ont touché la prime Macron et donc
la question
on voit bien c'est un détournement et
certains pour éviter d'augmenter les
salaires on fait cela pour 18% des
salariés c'est mieux de le dire comme ça
que c'est un million on a l'impression
que quand vous dites 5 millions tout le
monde l'a touché revenons aussi 18% des
salariés l'ont touché 82 % donc n'aurait
rien touché parce qu'on n'a pas vu une
augmentation massive des salaires en
France sauf là où il y a eu des luttes
et à chaque fois ça a payé donc vous
avez une question autour du salaire et
autour évidemment du salaire brut et net
et de la part brut du salaire socialisé
qui lui irrigue les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale ce que ne fait pas la
prime Macron et si on continue à ce que
l'ensemble aujourd'hui des négociations
d'un ao tourne autour c'est la prime ou
rien
nous-même nous allons assécher en
réalité les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale voilà le principe mais
évidemment c'est les ceux qui l'ont
touché on leur a pas dit ne la prenez
pas prenez ayez des négociations sur
l'augmentation des salaires monsieur
brouiller
merci monsieur le Président oui là en
fait la question c'est effectivement
comment ne pas affaiblir les contes de
la sécurité sociale par ces mesures
alors on avait au moment de du débat en
loi de finance un excellent amendement
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales de la rapporteur madame dounot
qui avait pour objet de rejeter le
principe de non-compensation à la
sécurité sociale du coût de la prime de
partage de la valeur que le gouvernement
a inséré subrepticement en intégrant un
amendement dans le texte considéré comme
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale sur
lequel les députés n'ont donc pas pu se
prononcer et je crois que c'était
effectivement une sagesse de notre
assemblée qui avait voté cet amendement
et qui mériterait donc d'être réinstallé
et qu'on arrête de dépouiller la
sécurité sociale
merci donc sur ces deux amendements nous
avons double avis défavorable je vais
les soumettre aux voix le premier donc
présenté par Madame ponce le 3154 qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le
deuxième
4475 présenté par Monsieur Baki qui est
pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'article 2 bis et nous avons
plusieurs demandes de prise de parole
sur cet article la première madame on
s'est mange
alors merci monsieur le Président alors
en plus de renflouer les caisses de la
CNAV cette proposition et la bienvenue
puisqu'elle permettrait de limiter les
ruptures conventionnelles à poser à
l'employé en raison de son âge
quand elle se substitue au licenciement
et effectivement les ruptures
conventionnelles collectives se sont
effectivement substituées au
licenciement économique collectif et
donc du coup on a évité dps selon le
Conseil d'orientation pour l'emploi
effectivement les pics de sortie parage
sont différents selon les types de
rupture concernant les ruptures
conventionnelles et selon la taille des
entreprises c'est le pic c'est entre 59
60 et 62 ans la fréquence des ruptures
conventionnelles et des licenciements
augmentent en fin de carrière ces pics
se déplacent donc aussi dans le temps
consécutivement aux modifications des
paramètres des retraites ce qui va
certainement se passer de nouveau en
effet si à l'approche de l'âge de la
retraite quelle que soit l'entreprise on
constate que les ruptures
conventionnelles et licenciement non
économiques se substitue aux démissions
mais attention
quand je dis cette phrase on retient
simplement les ruptures conventionnelles
mais il y a aussi c'est pas seulement
les ruptures conventionnelles mais aussi
les licenciements non économiques
essentiellement les licenciements pour
inaptitude aussi qui augmente avec le
report de l'âge d'ouverture des droits à
la retraite donc il y a une double que
corrélation entre les licenciers selon
l'âge entre les licenciements dit non
économiques qui soient des ruptures
conventionnelles ou des licenciements
pour pour inaptitude
rappelons-le le nombre de seniors
passons d'un emploi au chômage est
extrêmement élevé il est probabilités de
retrouver un emploi après 50 ans sont
très faibles donc nous accueillons cet
article positivement même s'il faut
veiller à ce que l'harmonisation du
régime social des indemnités de mise à
la retraite et de ruptures
conventionnelles n'incite pas enfin un
site plutôt à maintenir le salarié dans
le tromperie et non à banaliser les
licenciements quel que soit le motif je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Tissot
voilà on est en train de le vivre sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat nous étions
sur l'article 2 depuis ce matin 10h et à
l'instant
17h21 on vient d'attaquer un nouvel
article c'est à dire que depuis 10h ce
matin nous étions sur le même article 2
mais on vient de passer à l'article 10
de quoi s'agit-il pour tout savoir on va
poser la question à notre journaliste et
qui se trouve en tribune de presse vous
êtes toujours avec moi Alex alors deux
bis de quoi s'agit-il et bien content
l'article 2 bis c'est un article un
petit peu technique qui harmonise les
taux de cotisations sur les ruptures de
certains contrats de travail alors les
ruptures conventionnelles et les mises à
la retraite cet article il prévoit une
hausse des cotisations en cas de rupture
conventionnelle et une baisse des
cotisations en temps en cas de mise à la
retraite voilà pour harmoniser ces taux
de communication donc c'est un article
un petit peu technique il y a quelques
amendements qui vont être débattus
dessus ensuite on va passer à l'article
de terre qui est lui aussi un petit peu
complexe on sait pas un article
fondamental de cette réforme mais il va
mutualiser les coûts des maladies
professionnelles entre les différentes
entreprises au cours de la carrière d'un
salarié donc voilà on va parler
financement de maladies professionnelles
et après il y aura toute une série des
centaines et des centaines d'amendements
sur les recettes du régime des retraites
et on va parler fiscalité avec des
amendements notamment des sénateurs
centrist qui souhaitent augmenter la CSG
par exemple sur les revenus du capital
notamment sur les revenus du patrimoine
des revenus immobiliers et donc il va y
avoir des débats intéressants puisqu'une
partie de la majorité de droite et du
centre les sénateurs centrist vont
proposer et bien une hausse de la
fiscalité pour financer notre régime des
retraites et à les sénateurs de gauche
devrait les suivre ils leur manquerait
donc quelques dizaines de voix pour
faire passer ces amendements on va donc
y avoir un petit peu de tension dans ces
débats sur la réforme des retraites qui
qui s'annonce un noter un chiffre
Quentin il reste actuellement environ
1300 amendements avant d'arriver à
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans article
7 que les sénateurs à droite comme à
gauche aimeraient examiner demain le 7
mars pour la grande journée de
mobilisation sociale contre cette
réforme mais avec encore 1300
amendements restants et bien cet examen
de l'article 7 le 7 mars ce n'est pas
gagné oui merci Alex pour toutes ces
explications effectivement juste pour
compléter ce que vous venez de dire mais
effectivement en surveillera les
amendements notamment du centre triste
Jean-Marie vandlerenberg effectivement
un sur hausse de la CSG un retour dans
les missiles où il y a donc des demandes
de prise de parole introductive dans cet
article 2 bis et ensuite Alex vous le
disait il y a trois amendements examinés
de cet article grand groupe
et ce mode précis de rupture de contrat
de travail est totalement exclu du
dispositif de cet article pourquoi en
excluant les ruptures conventionnelles
collectives cet article passe à côté de
son objectif cet amendement du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
visent donc à intégrer les ruptures
conventionnelles collectives aux
nouveaux régimes social et fiscal
introduit à l'article 2 bis je vous
remercie merci avis du rapporteur sur
cet amendement
oui merci effectivement ce serait une
recette supplémentaire d'ailleurs
puisque ça irait sur le temps de la CNAV
donc on n'est pas insensible bien sûr
alors la Commission s'est penchée sur
les ruptures conventionnelles et on voit
bien qu'il y a un pic justement comme
par hasard de rupture conventionnelle 2
à 3 ans avant l'âge légal donc
59 60 ans par rapport à 62 ans et où il
y a ce consensus social j'ai découvert
ça parce que elle est partenaire sociaux
salariés ils sont attachés mais les
partenaires sociaux du côté patronal ici
sont attachés et résultats c'est qu'il y
a ces pics là alors moi je veux bien que
il trouve un certain consensus on va pas
s'en plaindre contraire je pense que
c'est mais pas quand même voilà donc on
peut corriger là aussi il faut qu'il y
ait une une volonté partagée de prendre
en compte les index seniors quand on a
vu cet amendement de l'Assemblée
nationale on a il y a quand même
l'assemblée à modifier le texte on va
peut-être pas y revenir quand même
surtout que ça allait tout à fait dans
la stratégie que l'on souhaitait puisque
on veut faire en sorte que les seniors
ne soient pas à la radiale d'ajustement
donc on pénalise un peu plus la rupture
conventionnelle devint on passe à 30 %
et en ce qui concerne la rupture de
l'employeur pour le passage à la
retraite c'est-à-dire qu'il peut se
faire à 70 ans qui a été taxé à 50 ans
on va pas pénaliser en harmonise c'est
une justice sociale me semble-t-il
allant dans cette philosophie et la
rupture conventionnelle collective
effectivement
je trouve que c'est un peu la variable
d'ajustement voilà donc ça m'a posé
question je on s'est posé on a on s'est
dit on va peut-être l'augmenter mais
avant de l'augmenter on va quand même en
parler aux partenaires sociaux donc
c'est une loi travail c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas pris l'extension de la
mesure individuelle à la mesure
collective et donc l'avis de la
commission est un avis au gouvernement
voilà demande d'avis au gouvernement
pouvoir un peu sa position par rapport à
ces ruptures conventionnelles
collectives
ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est le
même avis c'est une demande de retrait
ou un avis défavorable d'abord parce que
la question des ruptures
conventionnelles collectives et c'est un
outil pardon qui est plutôt reconnu par
les partenaires sociaux et surtout qui a
intervien dans un cadre défini et ce qui
a défini est lié aux difficultés
rencontrées par l'entreprise qui permet
d'accompagner d'une certaine manière des
départs volontaires donc si nous devons
reparler c'est plutôt dans notre cadre
que celui sur les retraites et j'ajoute
que la recherche de financement qui est
présentée comme le motif principal de
l'amendement que vous déposez mais n'est
pas un motif opérant pour une seule
raison
indépendamment des questions d'âge nous
avons à peu près 500 000 ruptures
conventionnelles par an il nous en
individuel nous en avons 10 000 dans un
cadre collectif et donc si nous
appliquons la majoration que vous
proposez au seul rupture conventionnelle
collective aux salariés plus de 50 ans
la recette générée serait donc 4 à 5
millions d'euros au maximum ce qui n'est
pas en rapport avec ce que nous
connaissons et ce que nous envisageons
avec comme effet négatif le fait de
venir altérer un des outils de gestion
en cas de difficulté d'entreprise pour
accompagner des départs sur la base du
volontariat avec un indemnité plutôt que
dans le cadre d'un PSE donc retrait ou
défavorable pour ces raisons
donc un double avis défavorable sur cet
amendement que je vais soumettre pardon
ah non excusez-moi oui vous avez demandé
la vie du gouvernement donc
j'ai pas donné un avis défavorable je
vous ai donné demandé votre avis et
maintenant effectivement je le partage
voilà il faudra revoir ça lors d'une loi
travail
donc nous avons bien un double avis
défavorable après l'expression de
monsieur le rapporteur
donc je vais le soumettre aux voix qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté
amendement 3096 madame blatrix comptable
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
l'hémicycle ou se tiennent ces débats je
suis accompagné de Valérie Boyer bonjour
vous êtes sénatrice LRD bouge du Rhône
un mot sur ses accusations venues de la
gauche qui vous dit que vous dites et
bien l'obstruction par votre silence
qu'est-ce que vous répondez vous à la
gauche ben je dirais que c'est tout à
fait l'inverse vous savez
malheureusement Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
tenu sa majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et il s'est laissé déborder par
l'extrême gauche et la gauche qui ont
volé le débat aux Français ce qui fait
que on a eu des vociférations à
l'Assemblée nationale et on n'a pas
discuté du fond nous nous souhaitons non
pas faire de l'obstruction cordiale ou
même silencieuse mais nous souhaitons
aborder tous les articles or nous sommes
enfermés dans la logique que le
gouvernement nous a imposé c'est à dire
un article qui nous contraint dans le
temps et on s'est parfaitement que quand
on dépose
le véhicule législatif choisi par le
gouvernement qui est contraint par
l'Artic 47 ans de la Constitution
dimanche à minuit
et moi ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on
puisse discuter de tous les articles
c'est essentiel je comprends l'angoisse
et la colère des Français une dette
abyssale un déficit du commerce
extérieur inédit 165 à 168 milliards
d'euros une souveraineté énergétique qui
a disparu tout ça ça a une incidence
déplorons des fleurons de l'énergie et
de l'industrie qui ont disparu également
sous Hollande et Macron c'est que vous
voulez pas voter la réforme du
gouvernement nous nous souhaitons voter
la réforme du Sénat la raison exactement
la réforme du Sénat qui est celle qui
préserve la justice sociale parce
qu'elle garantit les pensions vous savez
aujourd'hui on a le choix entre baisser
les pensions ou travailler un petit peu
plus est-ce que vous savez que quand le
général de Gaulle a mis en place le
système par répartition il y avait 5 à 7
actifs pour un retraité aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 1,7 actif pour un retraité
demain très vite on va être 1,2 ça veut
dire que si on ne prend pas de mesure
aujourd'hui nos enfants ceux qui
travaillent les jeunes aujourd'hui vont
devoir payer leur retraite et celle de
quelqu'un d'autre c'est absolument
intenable nous nous souhaitons préserver
ce système ne pas baisser les pensions
et surtout nous souhaitons remettre de
la justice là où Emmanuel Macron avait
complètement oublié les maires de
famille celles qui portent le système
par répartition avec la surcote et la
préservation aussi des avantages famille
nombreuses c'est très important
dans la deuxième partie du texte
effectivement une sensibilisation qui
qui se qui arrive je voudrais insister
sur une chose qui est très importante à
mes yeux en tout cas c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une violence qui
est faite aux jeunes femmes elles
doivent choisir entre travailler ou
avoir des enfants en rôle c'est
parfaitement beaucoup d'entre elles et
beaucoup de couples souhaitent avoir
plus d'enfants mais ils ne peuvent pas
les porter tellement la société et peu
accueillante pour qu'ils aient des
enfants il y a une pression sociale pour
ne pas en avoir au retarder le fait d'en
avoir donc nous nous souhaitons faire en
sorte que ces personnes qui souhaitent
avoir des enfants ne soient pas
pénalisés à la fois dans leur vie
professionnelle malheureusement on peut
pas l'examiner dans le sexe parce que le
gouvernement ne nous le permet pas mais
j'espère qu'on le fera bientôt mais
aussi dans leur retraite parce que c'est
sur elle que repose le système par
répartition il y a une mobilisation qui
s'annonce très importante demain avec
cette France à l'arrêt c'était l'appel
inter syndical comment est-ce que c'est
mobilisations vont peser ou pas
d'ailleurs dans les débats dans
l'hémicycle ben je pense que c'est
important que les Français s'expriment
je comprends qu'ils soient angoissés le
président le président de la République
leur a expliqué que l'argent coulait à
flot et que quoi qu'il en coûte et là et
bien principe de réalité je vous le
disais tout à l'heure problème de
souveraineté énergétique déficit du
commerce extérieur nous sommes parmi les
pays où on a le plus de prélèvements
obligatoires on voit pourtant les
services publics qui s'effondre donc on
est dans une situation dans la rue
difficile mais il s'exprime moi je pense
que le droit de grève c'est très
important c'est constitutionnel tout le
monde le sait mais faut pas empêcher les
gens de travailler parce que je crois
que les Français attendent de nous de la
responsabilité et notre responsabilité
c'est de faire en sorte que le système
de répartition soit sauvé parce que ce
système para répartition c'est celui qui
garantit des revenus au plus fragile en
France nous avons la chance
parce que notre système le permet et il
faut le préserver d'avoir un taux de
pauvreté des seniors qui est beaucoup
moins important que dans les autres pays
de l'OCDE donc on veut on veut le
préserver et on veut même améliorer le
sort de nos retraités une dernière
question dans Le Parisien le ministre du
socle qui parle d'une réforme de gauche
alors que vous êtes d'accord pour la
voté qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
écoutez Olivier du stop le pauvre dit ce
qu'il peut nous nous sommes d'accord
pour voter la réforme sur laquelle nous
avons travaillé nous sommes d'accord
pour remettre plus de justice possible
nous sommes vraiment très très loin de
tout ça enfin nous allons beaucoup plus
loin et un autre point qui me semble
très important on va parler de la
retraite des handicapés et on va parler
de la lutte contre des fraudes est-ce
que vous comprenez que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement qui procrastine depuis des
années et des années parce que quand
Emmanuel Macron a été ministre du Budget
François Hollande dans le Macron 1 et
dans le Macron 2 pour une chose qui est
essentielle c'est-à-dire le bien commun
des Français aujourd'hui qui était une
véritable passoire et bien nous nous
voulons remettre de la justice parce que
on peut pas demander des efforts aux
Français et en même temps avoir un
système qui n'est pas juste parce qu'il
est fradé on verra si vous allez jusque
là il vous reste
quelques jours et 2927 c'est le chiffre
exact c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important qu'on aille jusqu'au bout du
texte parce qu'il faut que les Français
sachent qu'il y a dans la réforme il
faut que les Francs nous sommes la
représentation nationale donc 1979
il y a des outils aussi législatifs
38 qui contraint un orateur pour un
orateur contre
le mettre en place je pense que c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui
écoutez il y a plusieurs façons de le
faire c'est la conférence des présidents
décidez mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas
voler une seconde pas le débat aux
Français sur ces questions aussi
essentielles ce débat a lieu au Sénat
c'est l'importance du bicamérisme c'est
la responsabilité des sénateurs d'aller
jusqu'au bout du débat qui vote ou qui
votent pas mais la moindre des choses
c'est d'en discuter et de et de montrer
aux Français ce que nous avons dans un
projet merci merci
à vous d'être venu ici au micro ça les
conférences on retourne dans l'émission
ou en Suisse c'est des Bains en direct
merci à mon taxe de 1% permet de couvrir
la totalité des besoins de 0,5% la
totalité des besoins parce qu'il
concerne la branche maladie
merci donc avis de monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements le
2353 et l'amendement de repli le 2362
alors effectivement c'est un amendement
qui décoiffe je dirais
[Musique]
c'est intéressant c'est ces histoires de
micro-taxe à chaque transaction on se
rend compte de rien on va acheter sa
viande son truc et il y a une toute
petite taxe ça passe inaperçu sauf qu'au
bout du compte quand même celui qui a
beaucoup de transactions il y a beaucoup
de taxes je suis qu'un peu de
transactions il est un peu tard mais ça
mérite d'être étudié
dans un plfsl rectificatif 2023 réussir
à bouleverser le système social pour que
le dispositif est un impact pour le
PLFSS
je crains que le Conseil constitutionnel
retoque le dispositif avec des arguments
beaucoup plus étayés que ceux qui
peuvent éventuellement lui servir pour
l'index au Seigneur voyez-vous je ne
voudrais pas qu'il est le derrière de
méprises donc il y aura aucune
répercussion sur l'année 2023 bien
entendu en conséquent je pense que c'est
un amendement d'appel nous avons bien
étendu entendu mais nous prendrons
plutôt des décisions quand la réflexion
sera peut-être un peu plus élaborée donc
à vie défavorable
je suis le ministre
merci monsieur le Président j'ai le
souvenir dans le cadre des discussions
du PLF à l'automne que le groupe UC
avait proposé un Big Bang de la
fiscalité immobilière là c'est un Big
Bang de la fiscalité sur notre système
de retraite dans un amendement mais moi
je suis toujours très favorable parce
qu'on est des réflexions prospectives et
qu'on réinterroge le système en
l'occurrence ce système nous fait sortir
du système pas répartition on est plus
dans la logique d'un système par
répartition ou ceux qui travaillent
financent la pension de ceux qui sont
retraités on est sur un système avec une
micro taxe sur tous les paiements
scripturaux donc c'est à dire d'un bout
à l'autre de toute la chaîne une
micro-taxe qui s'ajoute en réalité alors
je vous précise que les les services de
la Direction de la Sécurité sociale de
mon cabinet ce sont pas mal arrachés les
cheveux pendant de longues heures et
nuit pour essayer de regarder les
impacts de cet amendement on n'est pas
au bout de ce qu'on peut regarder en
réalité ça augmenterait les prélèvements
obligatoires dans notre pays puisque
manifestement selon l'étude qui a été
faite mais encore une fois qui mérite
d'être approfondie vous remplacez 320
milliards de cotisations par 350
milliards prélevés via la micro-taxe qui
viendra en plus s'ajouter à la TVA donc
en fait à la fin il y a plus de
prélèvements obligatoires en France la
question c'est sur qui est-ce que ça
pèse le plus et c'est là-dessus ou il y
a un peu une incertitude donc merci de
de porter ce débat parce que c'est
toujours intéressant de réinterroger le
système on ne souhaite pas sortir du
système par répartition par ailleurs on
a on manque d'études d'impact sur ce qui
implique cet amendement donc c'est une
proposition de retrait mais merci
d'avoir porté ce débat
merci Monsieur
vendeur belle
merci
à Michel canvett d'avoir soulevé ce
débat parce que j'avais rencontré à sa
demande d'ailleurs lorsque j'étais
rapporteur général les personnes qui
nous avaient effectivement
alerté sur cette possibilité
on n'a pas demandé la vie du Conseil
d'État c'est vrai ni du Conseil
constitutionnel mais j'avais simplement
souhaité avec Michel que on puisse
demander la vie de la Banque de France
par exemple puisque il s'agit de
paiement scriptural et donc que toutes
les transactions et on n'a pas eu de
réponse on n'a pas eu de réponse alors
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai entendu votre
réponse moi je souhaite qu'on creuse le
problème bien sûr que c'est un
amendement de d'appel pour effectivement
provoquer un peu parce que je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose là d'intéressant
porté par des banquiers bretons chez
bien vous allez me dire c'est la
Bretagne mais justement la Bretagne
s'est têtue et donc on maintient
effectivement cette idée de creuser
maintenant ça Michel de dire si elle le
maintient ou s'il le retire
ce cadeau
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement ça augmente un tout petit
peu les prélèvements obligatoires dans
la première version de l'amendement mais
j'ai plus comprendre que nous avions
encore quelques déficits à résorber et
finalement je me dis que s'il y avait
des recettes supplémentaires ça serait
utile pour le retour à l'équilibre de
l'ensemble de nos comptes publics et je
pense que vous ne pourrez que souscrire
à cela Monsieur le Ministre alors
le second amendement ne met pas fin au
système par répartition puisque dans le
second amendement que j'ai présenté
ne sont concernés que les cotisations
relatives à l'assurance maladie mais par
contre les autres cotisations et en
particulier les cotisations relatives à
la retraite que nous examinons
aujourd'hui elles perdure et donc ça ne
remet nullement en cause le système de
retraite par répartition auquel nous
sommes tous attachés mais j'ai
longuement souvent entendu ici dire que
la question de la finance
occupait beaucoup trop notre société il
y a un moment ce n'est pas tout de le
dire il faut se le dire aussi et bien
puisque c'est un problème essayons de
supprimer la fiscalité sur le travail
pour l'orienter plutôt sur la finance
c'est-à-dire sur l'ensemble des
mouvements financiers et je pense que
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens vont y
retrouver leur compte tout simplement
parce que et bien ils auront une
rémunération nette qui sera nettement
supérieure donc un pouvoir d'achat
nettement amélioré et en ces temps c'est
plutôt appréciable et puis les
mouvements spéculatifs participeront
beaucoup plus au financement de la
protection sociale en France donc c'est
quelque chose qui est pas mal donc je
pense que ce débat mérite d'être mené et
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité qu'il soit
effectivement mis sur la table dès
aujourd'hui
vous vous maintenez les amendements oui
d'accord ils sont maintenus donc nous
allons les soumettre aux voix avec un
double avis défavorable pardon madame
ponce pardon
merci Monsieur les présidents monsieur
le Président le corps n'a cessé de le
répéter le système des retraites ne
souffre pas d'un problème de dépense
mais d'un problème de recettes les
recettes principales ce sont les
cotisations sociales mais qui représente
à 90% des recettes en 1990 et ne
représente plus que 55% en 2021 selon
l'adresse et on sait pourquoi et tout
est censé être compensé nous l'avons dit
aussi mais tous ne l'est pas d'une part
et tout ce qui est compensé d'autre part
représente tout de même une perte pour
les contes de l'État qui elle se
compensera par des réformes
structurelles pour lutter contre son
déficit grandissant comme ce que nous
vivons actuellement les politiques
d'exonération de cotisations
représentent à mon cas à gagner de 74
milliards cette fois le déficit des
retraites dont parle aujourd'hui dont on
parle aujourd'hui c'est amendement âme
que les prélèvements obligatoires pèsent
sur le coup du travail mais le Conseil
d'analyse économique en 2019
recommandait d'en finir avec les
exonérations de cotisation au-dessus de
1,
Smith précisément parce qu'elles sont
inutiles par ailleurs cet amendement va
très loin puisqu'il demande de remplacer
toutes les cotisations sociales par une
taxe de 1% sur des paiements scripturaux
c'est à dire entre autres les virements
vous asséchez toutes les sources de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
prétendant que le coup serait neutre à
350 milliards ce qui est tout à fait
discutable ou du moins à démontré et ne
résout pas le problème de recettes qui
est le nom de toute façon nous n'avons
pas besoin d'un passage de cotisation à
une taxe nous avons besoin d'une
augmentation des ressources qui doit
passer par un dégel du point d'indice
des fonctionnaires une augmentation des
salaires une augmentation des
cotisations notamment sur les housses
salaires une augmentation et un meilleur
partage de richesse alors vraiment si
vous voulez avoir des taxes le vrai
problème n'est pas pourtant la méthode
de financement le problème c'est aussi
les super profits donc vous voulez une
taxe et bien une simple taxe qui fixe à
33% des bénéfices lorsque ceux-ci
excèdent 20% de la moyenne des années
2018 et 2021 rapporterait 7 milliards
selon l'Institut d'études politiques
c'est une ressource
donc c'est pas au-delà des questions
comptables c'est une mesure de justice
monsieur le ministre
non très rapidement pour ne pas retour
en salle des conférences ici au Sénat
Alexandre on vous rejoint tout de suite
dites-nous où en sommes-nous à 17h44 et
bien Quentin on débat actuellement d'une
proposition de Big Bang fiscal qui est
faite par un sénateur centriste Michel
cannabet sénateur centriste du Finistère
alors on le rappelle notre régime de
retraite il est financé par les
cotisations à la fois des salariés et
des employeurs pour financer les
retraites actuelles de nos retraités et
on le on le voilà on va on va le dire on
va l'expliquer dans ce dans ce débat il
y a un sénateur centriste Michel Canevet
qui propose de remettre totalement à
plat en créant une micro taxe de 1% sur
tous les paiements paiement scripturaux
et paiements électroniques et cette
micro-taxe elle remplacerait les
cotisations sociales elle aurait même un
rendement supérieur de 350 milliards
d'euros ce serait donc un Big Bang de la
fiscalité et de notre régime social le
gouvernement a mis un ami un avis
défavorable c'est ce qu'on appelle un
amendement d'appel c'est à dire c'est
pour créer une prise de conscience sans
espérer qu'il soit voté c'est cela un
amendement d'appel pour lancer un débat
mais où on sait que l'amendement a très
peu de chances d'être effectivement voté
au bout merci Alex on retourne dans
l'hémicycle ou c'est la sénatrice
communiste Florence cohenka la parole je
voudrais pouvez rappeler que çaissant
des critères de pénibilité qui
déterminent la sinistralité des
entreprises il y a malheureusement des
inégalités entre les salariés je pense
notamment entre les salariés femmes et
les salariés hommes la délégation
sénatoriale au droit des femmes a lancé
un travail en ce sens et les auditions
qui ont commencé confirment que les
femmes sont plus exposées aux muscles au
risque
musculoosquelettiques que les hommes en
effet les femmes représentent 60% des
victimes des troubles musculo
squelettiques et les ouvrières étant les
premières touchées de plus il y a
également un manque d'ergonomie de
l'environnement de travail la
multiplication des contrats précaires
des temps partiels subis des horaires
décalés une vie personnelle dense qui
entraîne un cocktail explosif et qui
explique aujourd'hui que nombreux sont
les femmes qui souffrent
particulièrement
dans leur lieu de travail et en plus la
pénibilité féminine et sous-estimée ce
que nous dit avec beaucoup de
démonstration la sociologue Caroline de
Pau la représentation de la pénibilité
c'est encore dans l'imaginaire collectif
bien plus celle du mineur que celle de
la caissière ou de l'aide à domicile en
effet pendant très longtemps le corps
standard pour la médecine a longtemps
été le corps d'un homme nous souhaitons
que la santé au travail de l'ensemble
des travailleurs et des travailleurs
soit mieux prises en compte pour
l'ensemble des entreprises pour ces
raisons nous considérons que la
Mutualité mutualisation du malus
participent à la déresponsabilisation
des entreprises je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci Madame
Poncet Monge
alors merci monsieur le Président alors
cet article donc introduit par un
Assemblée nationale pose quand même une
réelle question
cela peut être utile effectivement pour
l'embauche des travailleurs qui ont pu
changer d'entreprise et dont la dernière
entreprise qui aurait à le licencier
pour maladie professionnelle n'est
peut-être pas en totalité
responsable de fait cela peut constituer
une réticence à l'embauche pour autant
que l'exposition et pour autant que
l'exposition au facteurs de pénibilité
ne se poursuivent pas justement dans
l'entreprise dont parle l'entreprise
finale de fait si l'indemnité dépend de
l'ancienneté le taux ATMP impact
effectivement l'entreprise qui licencie
donc le problème est réel d'autant que
la fragilité du travailleur du fait de
ses expositions passées et de moins en
moins détecter de moins en moins prévenu
par la médecine du travail que vous avez
méthodiquement privé de ses moyens ainsi
elle ne sera pas en mesure lors de la
visite d'embauche dans cette fameuse
dernière entreprise de veiller à
l'adaptation du poste pour ce
travailleur en sachant son histoire son
exposition passée au facteurs de
pénibilité
on vient de revenir sur le fait qu'un
travailleur a de plus en plus de risques
d'avoir subi dans son con parcours
professionnel des expositions à des
risques accrus par l'intensification du
travail si on est parlé tout à l'heure
donc c'est la fameuse étude d'Arès qui
montre l'explosion de tous les facteurs
de pénibilité
vous évoquez souvent quand aux morts au
travail une méthodologie différente
entre pays européen c'est vrai mais cela
n'explique pas tout parce qu'on peut se
comparer à soi-même la France est l'un
des seuls pays d'Europe où le nombre
d'accidents mortels au travail donc du
fait de mal et donc du fait de maladies
professionnelles a augmenté passant sur
la même période de 557 à 585 donc cette
disposition ne doit pas servir à des
responsabiliser j'ai vu que c'était
quand même la crainte de ma collègue les
entreprises de leurs engagements pour la
protection des salariés et leur
obligation de préserver leur santé il ne
suffira pas à lever les freins dans
l'emploi pour des seniors pour
l'embaucheurs voilà ne retrouve pas
d'emploi mais enfin voilà
je nous nous soutiendrons cet amendement
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mais monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est un cycle de terre
qui prévoit la mutualisation entre les
entreprises des colliers ou maladie
professionnelles dont les faits est
différé d'antan et le bienvenu et comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure avec mes
collègues du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains nous
soutiendrons une mesure qui est une
partie de la réponse de l'enjeu de
l'emploi des seniors l'extension du
dispositif pour le régime des salariés
agricoles est également une bonne
proposition de la part des rapporteurs
car il s'agit malheureusement de
professions qui sont particulièrement
affectées par les accidents du travail
et les maladies professionnelles et qui
ont souvent connu plusieurs employeurs
avec des parcours pas toujours linéaires
donc il était important que cette
mutilation s'applique également pour les
régimes des salariés agricoles de
manière plus générale je pense qu'il est
indispensable et nous aurons peut-être
c'est les balles lors de la future loi
d'orientation agricole de mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité pour les métiers
agricoles
que ce soit par des horaires travail
très variables et week-end les jours
fériés la nuit l'utilisation de machines
de plus en plus complexe ou bien sûr
l'exposition aux produits
phytosanitaires les agriculteurs et les
agricoles sont particulièrement soumis à
cette pénibilité et assez risques
peuvent conduire qui peuvent conduire à
de très graves accidents du travail les
troubles musculo-squelettiques
constituent même la première cause des
maladies professionnelles reconnues en
agriculture
93,3% en 2016 faisons selon la MSA en
2017 le Conseil Général d'alimentation
de l'agriculture et des espaces ruraux
avec conduit une étude sur la pénibilité
des métiers agricoles études qui avait
mené au renforcement des critères pour
l'accès des salariés agricoles au compte
personnel de prévention de la pénibilité
le C3P malheureusement le retour en
arrière sur ces critères de pénibilité
du premier gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron aura été préjudiciable pour les
salariés agricoles par conséquent cet
article de terre est une bonne
initiative pour l'emploi des seniors
notamment je l'ai dit plusieurs fois
dans les milieux agricoles mais cette
mesure doit être accompagnée par une
meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité que nous vous proposerons à
l'article 9 merci
madame leouérou
merci monsieur le Président cet article
que nous nous apprêtons donc à examiner
prévoit que les modalités de calcul du
taux de cotisation ATMP puisse être
modifié par voie réglementaire pour
mettre je cite pour permettre je cite la
mutualisation entre les entreprises
découle liés aux maladies
professionnelles dont les faits différé
dans le temps dans l'objectif de
favoriser l'emploi des salariés
âgés dans l'amendement déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
estime que certaines entreprises
pourraient avoir des réticences à
embaucher des salariés seniors par
crainte qu'il déclare une maladie
professionnelle liée à une exposition
passée le gouvernement s'intéresse donc
à la prévention au travail c'est une
bonne chose en revanche que de temps
perdu alors que vous avez supprimé 4
critères de pénibilité en 2017 qui ne
sont d'ailleurs pas réintégrés dans la
réforme que nous examinons aujourd'hui
nous allons dans le sens de vos
intentions celui de lutter contre la
maladie
une maladie professionnelle et mieux
prendre en charge les personnes qui y
sont exposées et particulièrement les
salariés âgés mais il faut pour cela
revenir aux politiques que vous avez
détricoté depuis 2017 pour mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité de certains
métiers et permettre aux salariés de
partir à la retraite tant que leur santé
ne sait pas dégradé la mesure la plus
simple pour préserver la santé de ceux
qui travaillent dur et de ne pas les
faire travailler deux années
supplémentaires c'est le bon sens auquel
nous appelle le président de la
République le travail obligatoire
jusqu'à 64 ans les Français vous disent
NON et le diront demain dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
tout en reconnaissant l'usure que
provoque le travail à partir de
saintennage vous vous évertuez à vouloir
faire travailler les personnes plus
longtemps tout en reconnaissant qu'il y
a beaucoup de risques une maladie
professionnelle se déclenche chez un
salarié d'un certain âge votre seul
préoccupation c'est d'alléger les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les
employeurs pourquoi alors si votre
préoccupation est de ne pas effrayer les
employeurs et en particulier ceux des
PME et des TPE toujours selon maudire
avoir supprimé de nombreux critères de
pénibilité pourtant essentiels en termes
de prévention pourquoi ne pas revenir
sur la baisse de 17 ans à 5 ans de la
durée vérifier d'exposition à des formes
de pénibilité ou maladies
professionnelles de même pourquoi ne pas
revenir sur la suppression de la visite
médicale avant l'embauche cela aurait pu
être de véritables pistes pour trouver
le bon équilibre entre l'incitation à la
prévention et la nécessaire réassurance
de l'employeur toujours selon vos mots
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
merci avis de monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un amendement de suppression
justement de cette tour en direct ici en
salle des conférences vous êtes sur
Public Sénat merci à vous on va
rejoindre Alex pousse à Alexandre vous
avez suivi et bien pour Public Sénat
depuis la tribune de presse tous les
échanges depuis ce matin en ce cinquième
jour de l'examen de la réforme des
traites ici au Sénat faites-moi un peu
le bilan de cette journée s'il vous
plaît Alexandre et bien Quentin ce qu'on
peut retenir l'information de la journée
c'est que le Sénat a voté la création
d'un CDI senior pour inciter à les
entreprises à embaucher des salariés de
plus de 60 ans Alors ce CDI senior en
quoi ça consiste c'est un contrat de
travail pour les salariés de plus de 60
ans sans exonération sans cotisation
familiale pour les entreprises les
entreprises qui sont donc exonérées de
cotisations familiales sur ce CDI senior
et l'employeur peut mettre fin à ce
contrat une fois que le salarié a le
droit de liquider à sa retraite à taux
plein alors pour la droite et le centre
du Sénat c'est une mesure importante qui
est beaucoup plus ambitieuse pour
favoriser l'emploi du des seniors que la
mesure du gouvernement dans cette
réforme des retraites qui est à la
publication d'un index sur l'emploi des
seniors du côté du gouvernement bien on
était défavorable à cette mesure car on
la juge trop coûteuse notamment avec
cette exonération de cotisation
familiale et puis pour la gauche du
Sénat on a rebaptisé ce contrat ce CDI
senior et bien contrat de dernier
embauche en référence au contrat de
premier embauche qui avait valu
d'importantes manifestations en 2006 et
les sanitaires de gauche et bien ils
estiment que ces exonérations de
cotisations pour favoriser l'emploi sont
inefficaces donc ça c'est pour la mesure
votée par la droite ce matin et puis à
cet après-midi il y a eu un silence des
sénateurs les républicains et des
sénateurs centrist face aux amendements
qui ont été proposés par la gauche des
dizaines et des dizaines d'amendements
pour augmenter les cotisations notamment
sur les eaux salaires et sur les
employeurs des propositions alternative
pour financer notre régime de retraite
et puis aussi un temps de parole pour
les sénateurs de gauche les sénateurs
communistes écologistes socialiste pour
montrer qu'il y a d'autres manières pour
rééquilibrer notre régime des retraites
et face à ces sénateurs de gauche la
droite sénatoriale est restée
silencieuse qui fait que le sénateur
communiste Fabien gay a parlé
d'obstruction à silencieuse de la droite
qui refuse de débattre merci Alexandre
pour ce récit de cette cinquième journée
d'examen de la réforme des retraites
pour être totalement complet il reste à
l'heure où l'on se parle de 1917
amendements à examiner d'ici dimanche le
temps qui est compté puisque et le cadre
du projet de financement rectificatif de
la loi de sécurité sociale et très
contraint par l'article 47 ans donc les
sénateurs s'ils veulent aller au bout du
texte il faut qu'ils aient ils analysent
et qui les examinent 2917 amendement
d'ici à dimanche or et bien on n'a pas
énormément avancé puisque depuis ce
matin et les calculs de Public Sénat
nous examiner 94 amendements toute la
question maintenant est de savoir quand
est-ce que sera examiné l'article 7 vous
savez celui sur le décalage de l'âge de
départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
l'article 7 la gauche aimerait
l'examiner ce serait sans doute d'après
nos dernières informations dans la
soirée de demain et pour l'occasion PLUS
FINANCE sera en direct y compris très
tard dans la soirée en direct n'hésitez
pas à lire les articles de la rédaction
sur publics.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'info avec Thomas Huy dans sens public
c'est dans quelques secondes
[Musique]